[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinker view est ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
philippe bihouix et bien philippe
bihouix ingénieur je m'intéresse à
toutes les questions qui tournent autour
des ressources de la soutenabilité de
nos sociétés industrielles j'entends
djoko ici je dirige et enfin je co
dirige une société qui s'appelle carbone
4 et qui fait du conseil en transition
bas carbone et je préside une
association qui s'appelle de chic
project et qui milite pour la
décarbonation de l'économie alors on va
commencer par philippe bihouix
l'épuisement des ressources
l'épuisement des mets tout le club pour
la france
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
jeu j'aurais envie de commencer par le
fait que cette question de l'épuisement
l est
elle est pas forcément tout à fait
nouvelle je me suis amusé à remonter un
peu jusqu'au au sortir de la seconde
guerre mondiale ou des
conservationnistes américain des auteurs
comme william box vous faire fil aux
bornes qui ont commencé à alerter sur la
question des ressources et tout au long
des années 50 60 70 on a cessé
lanceur d'alert on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont voilà qui disait
qu'on allait aller vers la famine alors
c'était les ressources à la fois
renouvelable l'agriculture aussi les
ressources non renouvelables et puis en
face d'eux très très vite on a eu des
futurologues ou des économistes qui lui
expliquer que l'on allait au contraire
par le progrès technologique résoudre
toutes les solutions et ce débat-là qui
a vraiment traversé trois décennies
qu'on a un petit peu oublié finalement
dans les années 80-90 parce que c'était
un peu la fin de l'histoire la chute du
mur de berlin et autres à redémarrer
dans les années 2000 et très ému
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'on est en
encore au milieu de cette question là
c'est à dire que les le fait qu' on va
avoir un problème de ressources n'est
pas automatique pour tout le monde bien
au contraire on a on a des cornucopia
donc des gens qui misent sur le progrès
technologique et la corne d'abondance
qui nous promettent d'aller dans les
astéroïdes qui nous disent qu'on va
aller chercher plein de choses un peu
partout donc voilà c'est je crois qu'il
ya déjà une question un peu pédagogique
sur la question de dire est-ce que
effectivement on va avoir un président
sont sous pas est-ce qu'on peut tout
régler par la technologie
jean marc est ce que voulait rebondir
oui je vais un break de deux petits
calculs que j'avais fait que les tours
est assez amusant le programme apollo a
coûté en dollars d'aujourd'hui un peu
plus de 100 milliards et il a ramené six
mais si j'ai bien lu mes informations
quelques centaines de kilos
d'échantillons lunaires
donc ça mettrait la tonne de minerai
venus de l'espace à 300 milliards de
dollars s'est pas complètement sûr que
l'on puisse soutenir une civilisation
industrielle avec ce genre de prix des
ressources après la deuxième chose que
je vois qu'elle devrait rebondir c'est
que on a une illusion
malgré mon grand âge j'ai compris ça ya
pas très longtemps on est une illusion
d'économistes dans la rareté qui est que
comme on a tous été biberonné à l'école
avec l'idée qu'il y avait une élasticité
prix volume dit autrement si on a plus
c'est moins cher et s'il y en a moins
c'est plus cher on attend tous comme
signal de la rareté le fait que le prix
de quelque chose monter jusqu'au ciel et
en fait quand on regarde le passé on se
rend compte qu'il n'ya pas une matière
première pour lesquelles ce soit vrai
c'est à dire à moi j'avais commencé à
faire ça sur le pétrole j'avais regardé
quel était le prix auquel on achète le
pétrole sur le marché en fonction de la
quantité totale de pétrole produit dans
la nécessaire du volume disponible il
n'y a absolument rien qui ressemble à
une élasticité c'est pas parce qu'on en
a plus que ça vaut moins cher ou qui en
a moins que ça vaut plus cher il ya
aucun lien et du coup quand le prix ne
s'envolent pas vers les sommets en fait
on n'a pas l'impression que la denrée
devient rare et la rareté il faut aller
la chercher ailleurs et en fait j'ai eu
le grand privilège il ya quelques années
de rencontrer l'un des auteurs de
limitrophes dennis meadows 2000 recense
voilà à et qui m'avait dit au détour
d'une conférence en fait ce qui marque
la rareté je pense que philippe sera
d'accord avec moi c'est pas le prix de
la ressource sur le marché c'est la
quantité de capital qu'il faut investir
pour dégager une unité marginal de ce
qui vous intéresse donc une tonne de
cuivre supplémentaires une tonne de
pétrole supplémentaires etc hélas quand
on regarde cet indicateur là on voit
bien la rareté d'un certain nombre de
choses qui aujourd'hui font de la
civilisation industrielle qui est en
train d'augmenter dans les minerais ça
se voit pas ce que les teneur en minerai
sont en train de diminuer on voit ça de
manière continue sur le minerai de
cuivre ou un certain nombre d'autres
minerais important et sur le pétrole on
le voit aussi dans le fait que
l'intensité capitalistique des choses
qui sont aujourd'hui moderne et comme
les sables bitumineux pas terrible pour
l'environnement est 5 à 10 fois
supérieures à ce qu'elles étaient pour
le pétrole classique d'arabie saoudite
ou du ou des champs à terre que l'on
pouvait avoir aux états unis et c'est à
travers cet indicateur qu'on voit que
c'est de plus en plus difficile
d'accéder à ce qui nous intéresse chili
dans la référence à milo de me fait
penser à dans ce débat dans les années
70 effectivement entre cornucopia lors
les cordes du copain c'était le petit
nom dont il avait été affublé par les
par les lanceurs d'alert un peu écolo
est alors lé seul à appeler les autres
les les doomsday heures donc les
prophètes de l'apocalypse donc dans ce
convoi entre douce d'ailleurs et
cornucopia au moment de la sortie du
rapport au club de rome de l'équipe
windows les camps d'ucopia deviennent
hystériques littéralement parce
qu'effectivement c'est la première fois
qu'il ya un peu un travail qui est fait
sur la dynamique des systèmes etc qui
semble montrer qu'effectivement quel que
soit le scénario on va aller vers une
logique d'effondrement est alors dans
ces années 70 il ya bien un jeune
économiste s'appelle william nordhaus
qui fut publié un papier assez simple
faire plein de papiers en fait assez
sympathique à plaindre d'équations comme
les aiment les économistes et puis qui
conclut quand en fait on a négligé enfin
loups de l'équipe windows a négligé le
progrès technologique et que alors il
introduit en ces équations une
technologie qui t'appelle la bac stop
technology donc en français on dirait la
technologie qui tue et qui en fait une
énergie infinie totalement propre et qui
puise dans des réserves infinie alors
forcément une fois qu'on a cette
technologie qui tue c'est un peu plus
facile de résoudre le problème est de
dire que la croissance peut monter
jusqu'au ciel alors on peut enfin
jean-marc rigoles ou en pleurer parce
que les économistes ont une imagination
féconde en ce qui concerne la manière de
violer la physique mais voilà alors
soyons soyons gentils avec avec william
nordhaus donc peut-être vous avez vu
qu'il a eu le prix dit nobel d'économie
en 2018 pour ses travaux sur le carbone
d'envoyer quand on est assez bien parti
avec son son parcours démarre dans les
années soixante dix avec des choses
assez à ces truculentes son collègue
d'ailleurs qui a eu le prix nobel avec
lui paul romer lui estime qu'avec
l'économie de la connaissance est sorti
une interview il ya quelques années de
ça comme qu'on allait faire de la
croissance pour les cinq prochains
milliards d'années qui avait aucun
problème pour sa grâce à l'économie de
la connaissance pour passons enfin en
tout cas voilà on est vraiment dans ce
paradigme la deûle a effectivement delà
de la
substituabilité de toutes les ressources
et à dire effectivement s'il ya quelque
chose qui monte en prix eh bien on va
mieux recycler on va substituer on va
trouver d'autres solutions est ce que tu
dit jean-marc sur les prix me fait
penser à un paris célèbre qui a eu entre
un autre camp du copain qui s'appelle du
la juge line simone gélin salman qui
économistes aussi qui lui publie un
livre au début des années 80 qui
s'appelle the ultimate ressources la
ressource ultime qui est un clin d'oeil
évidemment la définition de ressources
ultime des géologues 1 et elle est en
fait la ressource ultime dans son livre
c'est c'est l'être humain
et bien en fait plus on sera nombreux
plus on sera heureux + ans développera
plus on aura de chercheurs etc parce que
voilà air et donc il fait un pari est un
pari qui est devenu célèbre au début des
années 80 il dit bah écoutez moi je suis
prêt à prendre le pari que n'importe
quelle ressource dans n'importe quel
terme dans le futur ce sera moins cher
et je suis prêt à prendre ce pari il ya
un monsieur qui relève le pari qui
s'appelle paul ehrlich l'auteur connu
qu'en fin de dyer s'élève à hauteur de
la population bomb début on 60,8 je
crois et donc ehrlich relève le pari ils
prennent un panier de cinq matières
premières l'or je crois qu'ils avaient
de tungstène
molybdène enfin je sais plus ils
choisissent bien leur leur sac
ressources et dix ans plus tard patatras
c'est un livre qui doit envoyer un
chèque à julian simón parce
qu'effectivement de 1980 1990 les prix
ont baissé et donc il ya sept alors il
n'a pas de chance parce que s'il avait
pris peut-être en 2005 ou en 2010 ça
aurait été un petit peu différent par
2010 parce qu'on est juste après la
crise mais ce que ça montre c'est
qu'effectivement le prix est pas
forcément un signal de rareté et que
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on est en train de
commencer à mettre en oeuvre ce sont des
mes gamines des mégane in plus profonde
robotisée climatisés pour effectivement
aller chercher des ressources qui sont
moins accessibles ou avec des avec des
toners de minerais qui sont moindres et
que c'est mes gamines elle demande
effectivement un investissement en
capital énorme et le fait qu'il doit y
avoir en face une demande énorme
jean-marc les politiques qui gèrent ce
cette petite
entre petrer comment
qu'entre patrie
cette petite phrase est lâchée sur la
rage est venu leur propre patrie donc le
les politiques
à propos tradition à des contradictions
il gère pas les contradictions c'est
justement ça le problème en fait quand
on regarde comment est structuré une
démocratie une démocratie et henry viii
en silo c'est à dire que j'ai des
agriculteurs j'ai un ministère de
l'agriculture j'ai des gens qui
transporte que j'ai un ministère des
transports où des gens qui se déplacent
j'ai des gens qui habitent donc j'ai un
ministère du logement j'ai des gens qui
produisent et en fait c'est fait en silo
parce que historiquement dans un univers
infini ça ne pose aucun problème de
gérer les problèmes de tous avec des
moyens croissants dans un monde où on a
plus de sucettes à distribuer comme je
crois que c'est à francis bouygues
compred cette maxime qui est dans un
monde sans croissance et pas de mauvais
manager mais de fait et c'est pareil
dans une société en croissance il ya
raisonnablement par beaucoup de mauvais
manager très compliqué de jouer peu de
corruption voilà ce qu il ya des
réactions mais à la limite on voit là le
c1 c'est un cahier des charges assez
facile donc le et la démocratie est née
dans un monde en croissance la
démocratie a commencé par naître en
grande-bretagne qui à l'époque avaient
un taux de croissance annuel faible mais
qui était déjà depuis deux siècles
supérieur à celui des autres pays
européens est précisément pour en
revenir à notre sujet parce qu'elle
avait sur son sol une ressource
énergétique dans laquelle elle a
commencé à taper avant les avant les
autres et le donc on est dans un
contexte dans lequel on peut promettre
en même temps plus à pierre plus à paul
plus à jacky et plus à simon et ça ne
pose strictement aucun problème et du
coup on peut organiser monde en silo il
ya un silo qui est responsable de donner
plus aux agriculteurs pendant qu'un silo
à côté responsable de donner plus aux
consommateurs et un silo à côté
responsable de donner plus aux gens qui
fabriquent des vestes tout ça ne pose
aucun problème dans un monde contre un
on est obligé de raisonner de manière
transversale
on est obligé de faire ça et en fait
toutes les organisations en silos sont
totalement démunis pour mettre du
contrôle de cohérence dans un système
qui a besoin de faire des choix une fois
qu'il est sous contrainte c'est très
très compliqué et par ailleurs la
démocratie est quand même une pyramide
inversée c'est à dire qu on a tous nous
français l'idée qu'une pile
on vit tous dans des organisations au
quotidien qui sont des vrais hiérarchie
moi je travaille dans une entreprise
c'est une vraie hiérarchie j'ai un vrai
pouvoir soit dit en passant sur mes
salariés qui est des virées cia mais il
travaille pas bien ils peuvent respecter
après mais c'est quand même un vrai
pouvoir si je travaille dans une
administration c'est pareil j'ai un vrai
chef qui a un vrai pouvoir un peu moins
fort mais il verra un vrai pouvoir quand
même le monde politique la pyramide est
inversé celui qui a le pouvoir c'est
l'électeur est du reste on le voit bien
dans les versions j'ai envie de dire les
plus aboutis de cette démocratie des
dernières années qu'on est qu'aux
dernières décennies qu'on ait connu en
france et dites moi ce que vous voulez
et je le ferai
l'exemple le plus caricatural c'était
désirs d'avenir de ségolène royal c'est
vous allez me faire mon programme
mais quand on regarde le programme de
hollande c'est pareil c'est un
inventaire à la prévert est là pour tout
le monde quoi les pompiers les jeunes
les lieux ce qui est bleu noir ceux qui
aiment le rouge selon une jambe en moins
ce qu'on y rendant plus enfin il y en a
pour absolument tout le monde
comme mitterrand a fait 110 propositions
donc ce ce système là est un système
remontant par essence j'empile des unes
sur les autres les demandes de tout le
monde et je dis que je vais tout faire
en même temps estoup liste c'est être
incohérent plus que populiste et je
pense que malheureusement il s'en
rendent même pas compte c'est ça le
drame c'est à dire que je crois qu'ils
ne s'en rendent même pas compte parce
que la quasi totalité des gens qui sont
dans cette classe là la classe politique
n'a pas conscience des flux physiques
sous jacents qui se cache derrière les
indicateurs qu'ils sont habitués à
manipuler un taux de chômage une
économie etc ils comprennent pas c'est
des gens qui enfin truc qui m'a fait
rigoler au moment de l'élection
présidentielle de hollande c'est que le
siège du ps était dans le viième son qg
de campagne était dans le septième et
j'ai pas quoi enfin bon bref donc on
fait des indicateurs pour élites
urbaines qui ont oublié non mais moi le
premier moi le premier je un jour j'en
suis victime comme tout le monde si je
fait pas l'effort intellectuel dans le
cadre de mon boulot de m'abstraire de ça
on fait des indicateurs pour élites
urbaines qui ne qui masque la réalité
physique sous jacente donc le monde
politique aujourd'hui il est totalement
à la rue ou à l'ouest je sais pas
comment on doit dire sur cette réalité
parce qu'il ne suit pas les indicateurs
qui sont décorrélés des indicateurs
économiques je vous suis parenthèses
ce monde politique cette caste
parisienne de monde politique qui tourne
sur elle même elle a bien des services
de renseignements c'est cerny isoloirs
terrible une fois que vous êtes en
fonction comme ministre comme ou pire
comme président de la république vous
êtes dans un isoloir et vous avez
d'abord vous êtes entouré de gens qui
sont payés pour ne pas vous dire deux
choses trop désagréable et donc vous
perdez les sondes que vous avez en prise
directe quand vous êtes en prise directe
avec les gens c'est des interactions de
30 secondes donc vouloir serrer la
louche ou vous les entendez vous les
entendez vous insulter parce que j'ai
pas quoi mais il n'y a plus ce travail
lent et patient et approfondie et puis
par ailleurs une fois que vous avez
promis alors dont le domaine qui me
concerne que par un vote à l'assemblée
nationale on avait violé la loi de
conservation de l'énergie c'est très
compliqué pour les gens avec lesquels
vous travaillez vous expliquer que non
non ça va pas marcher donc c'est un
univers qui est un univers qui est
aujourd'hui malheureusement
partiellement en apesanteur et puis il
ya 1 2 et le monde est devenu tellement
compliqué il y avait un très très bon
papier de sylvestre huet qui a été
journaliste scientifique à libération
qui est pour moi le meilleur sur nice
scientifiques de france sur son blog il
s'appelle science au carré où il parlait
de l'encyclopédie de diderot et où il
disait à cette époque là la totalité de
la science pouvait rentrer dans une
seule cervelle et la totalité de la
technique que le monde appelait à sa
rescousse pouvait être comprise par un
seul homme c'est à vous montriez à
quelqu'un un moulin un engrenage
voit une chaudière etc l'honnête homme
comme on disait à l'époque était capable
de comprendre avec ses sens ce que
c'était aujourd'hui la technique du
monde qui nous entoure et chapeau sens
d'à peu près tout le monde notre ami qui
est en panne nous filmer ne sait pas
dans le détail comment fonctionne sa
caméra nous sommes super dire voilà le
détail
10 d'autres comme tous les circuits
électroniques tout comment fonctionne le
réseau internet qui marche derrière et
c'est tout ça dans le détail 2001 ou
alors c'est one of a kind parce que il
ya l'essentiel des gens s'ils aussi que
l'essentiel des gens ne comprennent pas
donc tu piques us le pic us moi je vais
rentrer dans un métro pour je connais le
principe général le fonctionnement du
métro pour rentrer chez moi mais je
connais pas tous dans le détail non plus
donc en fait on a et je connais pas le
prix respectifs du système de contrôle
commande de la ligne versus jeu pourquoi
le volant du donc le lieu aujourd'hui
l'exercice de la démocratie qui
supposerait qu'on puisse avoir des choix
éclairés sur ce qui structure vraiment
notre univers qui est devenu
terriblement technologique en fait
échappe à la quasi totalité des gens qui
devraient faire des choix c'est c1 c'est
alors j'en reviens du coût et du coup le
monde politique infuse
représente finalement une valeur moyenne
de cette réalité donc pas plus que la
population qui les élisent ils ne
comprennent dans le détail le la
technique qui aujourd'hui se structurent
notre monde si je résume sa plus
trivialement on déjoue pas informés
qu'ils comprennent rien et qui brasse de
la fumée on a des gens peu ou mal
informés qu'ils n'ont pas le temps de
comprendre une fois qu'ils sont en
fonction et qui de bonne ou de mauvaise
foi prennent souvent des décisions qui
sont
à côté du problème à traiter ou qui ne
peuvent pas traiter le problème parce
qu'il aura manqué quelque chose dans la
définition du projet une bonne partie
d'entre eux essaye quand même de bosser
correctement alors qu il alors ce que
vous connaissez pas parce qu'en fait il
faut voir un truc dans le monde
politique c'est qu'il ya deux trucs
qu'on peut pas faire en même temps c'est
se hisser vers le sommet du pouvoir et
bosser ces dossiers donc ce que vous
allez voir traîner sur les plateaux de
télévision c'est ce qu'ils savent rien
et ceux qui savent quelque chose vous
les verrez pas sur les plateaux de télé
parce que c'est ce qu'ils sont un peu
besogneux dans les commissions
techniques à l'assemblée nationale etc
mais du coup vous les verrez pas qu'ils
essayent de bosser philippe oui je
partage beaucoup de
choses de ce que ce qu'a dit jean marc
alors d'abord sur la question de la
complexité technique effectivement alors
à complexer techniques elles datent pas
totalement d'hier ces rencontres entre
diderot et puis aujourd'hui il ya eu des
intermédiaires s'est pas fait remarquer
moi j'aime beaucoup par exemple
ouvrage de john kenneth galbraith le
nouvel état industriel donc publié dans
les années 60 qui avait eu un certain
succès parce qu'il avait un petit peu
pris beaucoup de monde à contre-pied
s'était déjà quelqu'un de très connu un
économiste extrêmement connue aux états
unis et alors ils disaient d'abord que
on était les états unis n'étaient pas
dans une économie
libéral mais dans une économie quasiment
planifiées à cause du poids du de la
commande publique et notamment de la
commande publique militaire et
industrielle et un polo compris des
états unis c'était assez intéressant
parce que en pleine guerre froide dire
que l'économie des états unis et est
dirigiste était assez assez truculent
déjà mais il disait aussi que le pouvoir
dans les entreprises n'était pas aux
actionnaires mais aux managers ce qui
m'apparaît assez intéressant parce que
effectivement grosso modo il ya des
conseils d'administration mais on vient
un peu avec ce qu'on veut en termes d'
analyse parce que justement il ya cette
complexité et puis on les accès les
actionnaires peuvent poser des questions
mais globalement c'est quand même les
équipes de management qui ont qui ont
qui ont plus ou moins de pouvoir et puis
effectivement il faut arrêter cette
complexité alors il lui l'avait
l'exemple de la du développement de ford
il prenait des combien de millions $ aux
centaines de milliers de dollars avait
coûté le développement de la forme de
thé ou du nouveau modèle d'un forte dans
les années 20 et puis de la ford mustang
dans les années 60 évidemment c'est
totalement explosif et cette complexité
lakiha
technologique qui a pris une nouvelle
dimension avec la mondialisation parce
qu'effectivement maintenant aussi y
compris une complexité ils ont deux
géographique avec dédé des réseaux de
centaines de milliers de sous-traitants
de sous traitants sous traitants etc
avec tous ces flux physiques c'est qu'au
développement et ses complexités aussi
juridique contractuel enfin tout ce qui
va avec fait que aujourd'hui
effectivement on sait bien difficile de
se dire si je essaye de toucher un
morceau quelque part ou deux dans le
mikado si j'essaie d'enlever un truc ou
de boucher je sais pas des barrières
douanières autre chose voilà alors on va
se tourner vers des prévisionnistes mais
qui ont à peu près la même capacité à
prévoir que que des météorologistes à
prévoir le temps de re 4 5 jours donc
c'est pas beaucoup
à 4 5 jours c'est devenu pas mal oui
voilà il vaudrait mieux prendre 20 jours
pour l'exemple à 20 jours très bien
donc donc voilà ça fait que déjà il ya
pour moi il ya sept la complexité elle
contribue au fait que l'idéal c'est pas
faire de vagues c'est à dire qu une fois
qu effectivement j'ai consacré mon temps
mon énergie est en général depuis très
longtemps à la conquête du pouvoir parce
que j'aime j'aime ça je pense d'abord
j'ai pas eu le temps de faire grand
chose d'autre quand même une pointe et
jean-marc mais que finalement ce l'idéal
pour moi cette page est embêté quoi
d'ailleurs c'est un peu pareil dans des
entreprises enfin un canton atteint
certains niveaux hiérarchiques
ce qu'on veut c'est pas que les c'est
pas que les gens qui sont en dessous
nous amène des ennuis c'est qu'ils nous
amènent des solutions et puis le mot
sida alors qu'est ce que t'en qu'est-ce
que tu ferais à bon d'accord donc on est
un peu dans cette logique là donc
finalement on a des gestionnaires qui
idéalement préférerais avoir pas trop de
grandes décisions ou façon n'ont pas été
sélectionnés sur leur capacité à être
des visionnaires c'est évident et depuis
trois ans il était visionnaire il
n'aurait sans doute pas été élu dans le
système donc le truc ce seulement un peu
la queue et puis enfin il ya la question
tu pointes tu parles de silos moi
j'aurais envie de parler d'injonction
contradictoires faire voilà on est dans
à tirer à hue et à dia et à vouloir
ménager la chèvre et le chou en
permanence et c'est ça qui est très
difficile c'est à dire que s'il n'a pas
une vision qui emporte le qui emporte le
l'entousiasme collectif à ça va être
effectivement difficile d'éviter des
tiraillements sur tout changement
finalement on sait que l'être humain
quand même relativement hostile au
changement même si on n'arrête pas de
parler d'innovation mais une vision
c'est un critère de tri en fait c'est à
dire c'est quelque chose si ma vision
c'est de construire une maison à ce
moment je trie dans mes heures ce qui
consiste à peindre
je le ferai pas enfin je le ferais
jolivet là je ne ferai pas ça donc en
fait une vision c'est un critère de tri
est effectivement comme aujourd'hui on
est en univers contraint et de manière
croissante c'est justement pour ça
qu'une vision serait particulièrement
utile parce que ça donne un critère de
tri oui non oui non de manière visible
et du reste pour finir là-dessus je
pense qu'une énorme supériorité d'un
trump sur un mac on sait que justement
ce type un projet nous on peut le
trouver farfelu délirant etc mais ce mec
a un projet il dit pas je veux réduire
le déficit budgétaire il veut faire un
mur ici une usine là plutôt que la dea
des plus de bagnoles mois de bagnols non
mais oui
la preuve c'est que il n'a pas du tout
l'érosion de popularité que à n'importe
quel dirigeant chez nous qui dans la
catégorie gestionnaire
de jeu ça a un pouvoir de séduction fort
d'être capable de dire je vais faire ça
encore une fois avec mes critères de
jouer terre
ça fait bander personne son déficit
budgétaire enfin j'ai pas vous
y laisser des gens mais dans le mauvais
sens
oui bon on est d'accord
on se retrouve
très concentré oui
on
va où là pour et visionnaire
il faut faire quoi rétablir une société
technocrates met un vote sans hésiter
alors il dit être visionnaire en fait
c'est très décidé de réparer parce que
guy la cause est juste avant que c'est
très attaché à gali taristas c'est très
différent mais la machine calcul tous
non à la flotte paroles respectifs
absolument en envoie ça ou csa est
donc le nom ce que je voulais dire c'est
que c'est définir ce que c'est qu'une
vision qui s'impose à tous en fait ça ne
peut pas exister parce qu'à un moment
une vision relève d'un choix éthiques
ce qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui c'est de
la cohérence dit autrement moi je peux
avoir une préférence et à ce moment les
forts que je dois faire c'est que ma
préférence articule de manière cohérente
donc je préfère ça il faut que je
comprenne que la contrepartie c'est que
j'aurai passé et à ce moment ok dans le
domaine qui me concerne à savoir celui
de la question du monde fini j'ai envie
de dire alors je le prends pas sous le
même angle que philippe mais là le grand
choix pour moi il est très simple c'est
on cherche à durée où on cherche pas
durer si on cherche pas à durer c'est
pas la peine de s'exciter avec des
questions d'environnement etc tant que
ça dure ça dure plus il faut qu'ça dure
pas ça dure pas dit autrement si ce qui
m'excite c'est d'avoir la délicieuse
sensation d'apesanteur je me jette du
haut de la tour eiffel tant que ça dure
ça dure puis il faut que ça dure pas ça
s'arrête bon si ce qu'on veut c'est dur
et aujourd'hui la contrepartie c'est
qu'on doit se mettre au régime et la
vérité politique indicible c'est que ce
régime concerne même le smicard c'est ça
la vérité politique un disciple serre
que même lui il est déjà malheureusement
et je dis pas ça parce que je les aime
pas c'est juste ce que disent les
chiffres canton oui entre autres c'est
sale c'est ça le problème alors je ne
dis pas qu'il faut ne pas avoir d'
empathie ne passait que il faut pas
considérer que monsieur ghosn ce qui est
en train de se passer du reste et dont
on peut être entendues doivent se serrer
la ceinture avant mais mais mais
globalement malheureusement le niveau
global de consommation du français
ordinaire est au dessus de ce que la
planète peut nous fournir pendant des
siècles et des bides et d'ailleurs c'est
très au dessus et on est
à quatre milliards d'individus sur la
planète c'est très au dessus donc ou
bien on dit on s'en fout c'est pas le
sujet donc tant que ça passe ça passe et
puis à un moment on va monsieur meadows
finira par avoir raison c'est à dire
qu'une fois qu'on a pompé les capacités
du système le système s'effondre de
toute façon on aura moins un jour pas
dans des siècles
plus tôt des décennies ou bien à
l'échelle mondiale et à mon avis en
europe ça a déjà commencé
pour revenir plus tard ou bien on dit
non non ce qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment dur et est à ce moment on a la
même le même raisonnement que le type
qui mange trop qui fume trop qui boivent
trop qui boit trop il doit se mettre au
régime quoi cesser ces examens tant que
c'est ça le premier choix fondamental
tant qu'on n'a pas tranché ce premier
choix fondamental qui est
fondamentalement un choix de préférence
un choix affectif un choix éthique
quelque part
en fait les problèmes derrière on sait
pas les traiter
et ben justement dire on veut avoir en
même temps de l'environnement et de la
croissance on veut avoir en même temps
plus de consommation pour tout le monde
et moins d'emmerdements pour la
collectivité c'est à dire qu'on ne sait
pas traiter ces problèmes là non mais on
ne sait pas et aujourd'hui le problème
du politique c'est qu'il ne sait pas
tenir un défaut d'un discours adultes
pardon à la population et faire la
pédagogie du problème en disant écoutez
je suis pas superman donc on fait ça on
fait ça et vous préférez quoi et puis en
fonction dont on commence par expliquer
aux gens pourquoi c'est comme ça que le
problème se présente de cette manière et
pas autrement que c'est désagréable à
entendre très désagréable à entendre les
goules et coûteux
moi j'ai le souvenir amusé de raymond
barre disant vous allez en baver et que
ça a pas spécialement rendu impopulaire
alors bon certes c'est à une époque on à
la pâte en bas avec ça mais
je j'ai la naïveté coupable c'était
encore très jeune mais j'ai naïveté
coupable de penser que quand on fait la
pédagogie du problème aux gens en
servant des propres pour des andouilles
on en retire un bénéfice de toute façon
philippe l'important c'est que la chute
c'est l'atterrissage
non j'aurais fait ça plus plus
philosophique j'aurais dit l'important
c'est pas la cible c'est le chemin de
lao-tseu c'est à dire que moi je pense
que ça va être très difficile façon
c'est très difficile en énergie
situation très difficile pour plein de
l'azerty nation c'est chou voilà sans
donner alors la cible ouais ça fait un
peu consultant g
attendant prônant une autre vie le
france avait été extrêmement difficile
de demander aux gens de se serrer la
ceinture alors déjà fraises se dire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire exactement
c'est ça la ceinture pour une logique de
solidarité inter générationnelle c'est
finalement à se dire parce que dure et
moi je sais que finalement je vais pas
durer enfin sauf s'il rompt alexandre
est à nouveau invité et que c'est moi
qui vais effectivement vivre mille ans
le premier d'aidé qui va vivre milan est
déjà né et c'est peut-être moi en fait
je ne sais pas encore qu'est ce que tu
as mis en garde et voilà mais à part si
on est dans une logique un peu trop et
humanisme on pourrait en discuter et
éventuellement une autre fois
idéologique on bosse et oui c'est les
deux enfin louis idéologie
transhumanistes oui tout à fait nouvelle
religion presque on pourrait dire bon à
part ça on va dire demain nous serons
tous morts disait votre ami keynes donc
c'est vraiment de la solide durée ça
veut dire de durer ça veut dire que les
conditions de vie de des générations
futures soient pas trop entamé peut-être
agréable parce qu'il y aura encore je
sais pas des girafes et des rhinocéros
enfin bon voilà de quoi manger de quoi
manger à tarir autre chose alors le
peuple sait que la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
elle me paraît difficile à mettre en
oeuvre en tout cas collectivement je dis
pas dans la petite troupe de chasseurs
cueilleurs avec le grand-père le père la
mère les enfants ou là effectivement on
peut se dire que peut-être je sais pas
où la gestion des biens communs enfin il
ya des expériences à une certaine
échelle qui montre qu' il ya des
possibilités mais quand on commence à
être quelques milliards ou quelques
dizaines de millions qu'on va avec notre
bulletin de vote cette solidarité là
elle est un peu compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre à mon avis d'autant plus qu'on
n'arrive déjà pas à mettre en oeuvre une
solidarité intra générationnelle c'est à
dire de venir en train tout on concède
soit au sein d'un même pays parce qu'il
ya des grandes inégalités et des soit un
pays à un autre parce que voilà quand
même si maintenant aujourd'hui on sait
que les classes sociales traverse un peu
différents pays donc moi je crois que si
solution il y a alors elle va être très
compliqué
bon chanteur disait quand le bateau
coule l'équipage peut rester à boire un
coup sur un banc à coup sûr le pont ou
bien peut courir aux pompes bon il faut
courir aux pompes allons-y on essaye
d'un peu de de réfléchir un peu tout ça
et je crois que s'il ya une solution il
faut qu'elle le il faut qu'elles
apportent un peu de 2,2 de bonheur où je
sais pas comment l'on vient enfin de
changement positif tout de suite parce
que sinon en gros c'est je me serre la
ceinture mais qu'est ce que j'ai en
échange alors déjà et la question sur ce
que ça veut dire de se serrer la
ceinture parce que veut dire quoi se
serrer la ceinture d'un point de vue
disons énergétique et consommation de
matière alors est ce que ça veut
forcément dire se serrer la ceinture
parce que d'abord on sait que les désir
le désir et mimétique on sait depuis
longtemps je je je je mon désir c'est ce
que désire le voisin c'est parce que je
désire moi ça n'existe pas mon propre
désir il est il est construit
socialement donc effectivement je suis
irrité si mon voisin de 2 bureaux est
allé aux maldives cet hiver et puis fait
du jet ski le week end à moi si je fais
pas de g.skill week-end et je vais pas
aux maldives je me sens un petit peu
embêté dans mon désir mimétique m'ont
très bien mais il ya des choses qui sont
y compris éventuellement
relativement cher je sais pas prenons
l'opéra bon l'opéra sais c'est pas c'est
pas neutre en carbone mais enfin c'est
cds instruments avant l'hiver il ya
plein de gens dedans c'est presque sans
doute le bon les gens chauffent eux
mêmes à 100 watts par personne la salle
bon voilà et pourtant l'opéra c'est
hyper cher c'est hyper élitiste enfin
voilà donc c'est la preuve que du coup
il est l inverse il ya des sports sans
doute un peu plus populaires qui sont
qui sont sans doute beaucoup plus
prolongeant sert donc bull le football
dont je m'étais amusé à faire un calcul
au sur la consommation des espaces juste
au mètre carré le plus haut rhin plus
horrible c'était plutôt le tennis parce
que son nombre de personnes et en nombre
d'heures m² fallait bien jouer au ping
pong au basket et le football est un
sport collectif c'était plutôt pas mal
et en plus on peut y jouer après la
moisson dans les champs dans l'époque
j'ai dédié éventuellement des des
terrains donc à la limite c'est pas le
plus de pub autour de la consommation
avec le football voilà voilà non mais
tout ça pour dire que voilà c'est il
faut trouver d'abord il faut un peu
faire le tri il ya des choses qui nous
coûte beaucoup en termes d'énergie par
la manière dont on est organisée etc
mais qui apporte pas forcément beaucoup
de beaucoup de beaucoup de plaisir de
bonheur de
et je pense que les mêmes les
économistes avec leurs calculs un peu
obtus montre à s'effacer bien assez
facilement qu'à partir d'un certain
niveau de pib oui au début c'est très
corrélé évidemment mais que passer à
certains de niveaux de pib par habitant
bah finalement le voilà le l'habitant de
pittsburgh et pas tellement plus heureux
peut-être que la bible habitants de
strasbourg donc il ya déjà ça prouve
déjà que c'est pas totalement corrélée à
l'énergie et aux matières premières et
puis après il ya la question
effectivement de la rivalité mimétique
et donc la question des inégalités et
donc pour moi si on n'est pas capable
d'apporter en même temps qu'une solution
des solutions ou des propositions
qui demanderont un petit peu des boues
j'ai effectivement d'organisation de
culture de
d'impôts et autres
et qui font pas plaisir à tout le monde
parce qu'il ya forcément des gagnants et
des perdants quand même dans tout ça il
faut qu'on soit capable d'assurer voilà
d'apporter des choses sympathiques aux
gens alors est-ce que c'est au tour de
l'emploi parce qu'aujourd'hui moi je
trouve que on la start-up nacion mais
moi je trouve ça tellement épuisant
cette logique de dire alors on est dans
l'innovation innovation innovation alors
attention si on est en retard il faut
accélérer pour rattraper les autres mais
si on est en avance faut surtout pas
s'arrêter de courir parce que les autres
courent derrière donc cette logique un
peu de la reine rouge la dame diop
éléments c'est totalement enfin et jusqu
où et comment donc cette nouvelle valve
nouvelle vague de robotique de de
numérisation d'intelligence artificielle
avec tout ce buzz totalement stupide
pour partie parce que venir chacun y met
un peu ce qu'il veut et quand on regarde
la réalité des choses et quand même pas
forcément tant que ça de l'application
concrète intéressante
voilà est-ce que c'est ça qu'on veut ou
est-ce que c'est autre chose et qu'on
doit effectivement se aller vers des
valeurs des choses qui sont peut-être
plus plus culturel qu'économique plus un
emploi pour tous
l'élite et ou alors voilà j'en sais rien
frugalité sobriété mais voilà c'est
toujours pareil frugalité ça va si c'est
moi qui prends ma douche froide avec
jean-marc passe son temps à prendre des
bains à 40 degrés avec 300 litres d'eau
à un moment on va pas être d'accord sur
tout si on est voisins et une masseuse
voilà donc que jacuzzi
chacun ses goûts il faut pas jouer
donc c'est ça la question c'est que
l'effort doit être partagé
si et si et fort il ya il doit être
partagée est plutôt à réduire les
inégalités qui à les augmenter pas
simple pas évident dans un monde
complexe comment tout ça fonctionne et
les interactions économiques même pas à
réfléchir à ça et puis donner
effectivement un projet qui qui fait
plaisir à une majorité de gens ou se
rendre compte qu'on va plutôt dans le
bon sens que ça avec des trucs parce que
on voit ce qu'on a gagné peut-être un
truc et m'envoie pas aussi ce qu'on a
perdu aujourd'hui que vous me perdre ou
ce qu'on va perdre ce qu'on est en train
de perdre c'est la logique de je sens
qu'il faut repasser un moment la parole
à jean-marc est le cette logique du
décalage de points du point de référence
connaissez ce truc-là de shifting
baseline donc c'est daniel pauly un
chercheur sur les sur les ressources de
poissons qui a lancé ça dans les années
90 je crois donc c'est il a montré de
manière assez incroyable que finalement
en les scientifiques ihés devez calculer
les stocks de poissons en fait ils
rentraient dans la carrière à un moment
et puis du coup il avait en tête un peu
hein
une logique de ce qu'étaient les
populations de poissons à ce moment là
un endroit donné ce qu'ils étudient et
puis que la génération d'après qui
arrivent et 25 ans plus tard est en fait
eu s'il n'y avait pas la même population
parce qu'évidemment savez diminué on
avait un peu vidé les mers entre temps
et du coup il partait sur un autre point
de référence est donc le point de
référence au décalé pour faire simple le
grand-père n'appelait pas un gros
poisson de pêcheurs grand père s'était
pas la même chose que le pêcheur père où
le pêcheur fils est ce qui est génial
dans ce truc du décalage de points
différence c'est que ça marche pour tous
y compris le pétrole ça marche pour
notre perception du confort ça marche
pour notre perception de ce qui est de
ce qu'est un minimum de niveau de vie ça
marche pour pourvoir al'inverse la salle
à la dégradation du niveau de vie les
embouteillages la saturation les
difficultés dans les transports voilà
est en fait l'être humain
malheureusement est malheureusement mais
heureusement sur tout et est très
adaptable et dans les deux sens et donc
il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on on peut
monter on a l'impression qu'on a plein
de choses qu'on progresse et qui sont
améliorées mais en même temps on a perdu
plein de choses simples et et papillon
pour les plus peut-être pour les plus
romantiques et puis c'est d'autres
choses bien bien sonnantes et
trébuchantes pour pour les autres et
malheureusement le 19e siècle a montré
qu'on pouvait aller assez loin dans la
dégradation des conditions de vie
consciente et en or alors certains
survivants avec le guano de l'amérique
du sud des îles oiseaux du chili et les
cartes les cap hornier qui faisait le
tour donc il ya la question de la
nourriture je suis d'accord avec toi
jean marc mais voilà globalement
malheureusement je m'absente que on a
une espèce de lancer ça va être très dur
malgré le succès de la chaîne de
l'inversé pour les questions
effectivement de prise de pouvoir et
autres et que du coup cette lancée elle
nous amène vers des conditions de vie un
peu dégradée et que quelque part
malheureusement pour le pour le meilleur
comme pour le pire les générations
futures vont s'adapter jean-marc ou pas
si alors ça dépend ce qu'on appelle une
adaptation ça dépend si on regarde
d'adaptation de l'espèce ou l'adaptation
de la totalité des individus l'espèce
d'adaptation de l'espèce je suis pas
très inquiet comme l'homme est une
espèce extrêmement ubiquiste on est
capable de survivre des tropiques
jusqu'au groenland et c'était déjà le
cas il ya des dizaines de milliers
d'années donc on ya des milliers
d'années donc qui reste de quoi
perpétuer l'espèce sur terre ça je
parierais pas mes économies sur le fait
que ça va se passer par contre la
quantité de représentants de l'espèce
qui sera encore présente sur terre dans
un siècle et vivant à 70 ans à la
naissance et le pet les paris sont
ouverts
on est beaucoup moins assurée pour pour
revenir sur la question du bonheur en
fait c'est clair que ce dont on a besoin
c'est alors je vais essayer de mettre
quelques chiffres derrière la question
de la consommation matérielle
quand on parle de contracter
le pouvoir d'achat ou le de quoi est ce
qu'on parle on ne parle justement pas
des questions connaissance parce que une
fois qu'on a un toit et de quoi manger
et effectivement on peut faire
indéfiniment de la croissance du pib en
compte en considérant que les
connaissances qu'on acquiert val chaque
jour quelque chose puis ça se rajoutent
puis ça se rajoutent puis ça sera jouée
depuis c'est sans fin sauf que ça ne
correspond à rien j'ai envie de dire de
matériel
là où l'on commence déjà à voir les
signes d'une contraction matériel en
europe alors l'approvisionnement
énergétique en europe est passée par un
maximum en 2006 s'est passé par un
maximum en 2006 parce que les trois
premiers termes de l'approvisionnement
européen c'est les combustibles fossiles
charbon pétrole gaz le charbon est en
déclin géologique en europe depuis le
milieu des années 80 en grande-bretagne
s'était même bien avancé début du 20e
siècle mais globalement un milieu des
années 80 depuis la production
européenne a été visé par trois et
importé du charbon en grande quantité
c'est pas commode parce que le charbon
est un pondéreux et c'est se laisser à
un solide donc compliqué le gaz en
europe est en déclin depuis 2005 c'est à
dire le moment où la mer du nord a passé
son pic de production est à l'époque la
mer du nord faisait 60 ou 70 % de
l'approvisionnement européen dans vachon
compris
et importé rapidement du gaz c'est
compliqué on a mis je comparais 20 ans
je crois va faire notre stream 1 ou 15
ans donc c'est pas si et le pétrole est
en déclin en europe depuis 2006 qui est
l'année où le monde a faim ces deux ans
avant l'année où le monde a passé son
pic de production sur le conventionnel
ce que l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie a fini par avouer entre
guillemets dans son dernier world energy
outlook donc le world energy outlook de
fin 2018 là il a dit le pic de
production du pétrole conventionnel sur
tout ce qui n'est pas les sables
bitumineux du canada et tout ce qui
n'est pas le che l'oeil le fracking
pétrole de schiste ce qu'il faut si j'ai
un chili tout ce qui est facile à aller
chercher ces 2008 d'accord et depuis ça
a perdu deux millions et demi de barils
jour sur une production qui doit faire
dans les 80
voilà donc c'est pas encore on n'est pas
encore à la hausse mais ça commence à se
voir
et c'est ce truc là en 2000 sa fin sur
la période 2005 2008 ce qui a provoqué
le choc pétrolier qu'on a connu à ce
moment là donc pétrole en baisse en
europe + alors eu un petit sursaut
depuis 2014 ce qui a fait la croissance
de la fin du mandat de hollande et du
début de mandat de macron
royal au bar
il ya déclin du gaz déclin du charbon
déclin du nucléaire parce que les
européens 10 ckac à berck donc il reste
les nouvelles et notabilités de l'hydro
parce que l'hydro sait capter la pluie
qui tombe sur les montagnes et donc une
fois qu'on a capté 90 % de ce qu'il
tombe sur les montagnes ça y est la
messe est dite ce qui est à peu près le
cas en europe et donc il reste les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables qui ne
sont absolument pas capable vu leur
intensité capitalistique de compenser le
déclin du reste
du nouveau chig c'est non c'est à ne pas
avoir compris la physique c'est juste
enfin les énergies renouvelables mon
sort il ya deux siècles monde était 100%
vénère d'accord on n'avait que des
moulins à vent des brûlures ou de la
biomasse la traction animale dans
l'agriculture vous n'avez que ce à quoi
il paraît qu'il y avait un peu dans
tourbe qui aurait fait la richesse des
hollandais dans les siècles ah c'est pas
possible oui on avait en fait le charbon
on a des traces d'utilisation il ya 3000
ans était avec globalement ce qui est le
gros de l'approvisionnement énergétique
européen il ya deux siècles c'était bien
à cause de ça que l'effort était en
train de s'effondrer soit dit en passant
pour alimenter les forges c'était du des
énergies renouvelables enfin pas
toujours renouvelée mais en renouvelable
et on est passé aux énergies fossiles
parce que les énergies fossiles sont
extractives de l'environnement de
manière considérablement plus facile et
en plus elles ont déjà leurs fonctions
de stock alors utiliser du vent pour
moudre du grain c'est pas un problème
parce qu'on a le sol juste après donc
une fois qu'on a le grain à moudre
s'appelle la farine on peut stocker
cette farine facilement et donc si on me
devant une fois par semaine une fois
tous les quinze jours c'est pas très
grave l'électricité c'est plus compliqué
à ce stock très mal donc le donc
l'approvisionnement européen est en
déclin depuis 2006 on a eu une rémission
depuis 2014 2014 après 2014 on est
remonté 2015 2016 2017 2018 peut-être
encore 2010 ça va pas durer indéfiniment
donc ça va repartir dans l'autre sens et
à ce moment là tout ce qui nécessite des
flux physiques va repartir dans l'autre
sens la production industrielle les
mètres carrés construits les tonnes
kilomètres sur les routes près tous les
flux physiques donc en fait quand je
parlais tout à l'heure de pouvoir
d'achat matériel qui va se contracter
ses devoirs basham matériel d'accord
c'est tout ce qu'ils se touchent donc
l'alimentation qu'on achète avant
l'énergie abondante enfin ou au début
plus exactement en 1930 un américain
consacré le quart de ce qu'ils gagnaient
à manger et la danse était
essentiellement des produits bruts
c'est-à-dire que alors pardon de ses
propos sexiste mais madame michu à les
acheter aux paysans d'à côté des
poireaux et d eux pour faire le frichti
pour monsieur michu qui partait au chant
ou à l'usiné bon et c'était donc des
produits bruts aujourd'hui la dépense
alimentaires des français en plus c'est
essentiellement autre chose que des
produits on paye la logistique la
construction de magasins des salaires de
magasinier de casse hier des campagnes
publicitaires les rémunérations
d'actionnaires des usines etc c'est
toujours de la bouffe c'est là quand
vous allez passer votre ticket de caisse
dans un supermarché en fait les 80% de
ce ticket de caisse qui n'est pas de la
nourriture qui est autre chose et
pourrait pourtant la fraction de ce
qu'on dépense au sens de l'insee pour
manger est passé de 25 à 10
en comptant le hors domicile à la
restauration etc mais en fait ça aurait
dû passer de 25 à 2 si on avait
correctement compte et en multipliant la
viande qu'on consomme par un factor 5 en
deux siècles donc enfin pas en depuis
1930 merlus siècle donc et tout ça c'est
l'énergie qui nous l'a offert donc on
prend dans n'importe quel domaine en
fait le pouvoir d'achat matériel à
augmenter parce que la fameuse
productivité du travail dont on parlait
au début de cette discussion que les
économistes attribuent à soi disant
progrès technique en fait c'est la
croissance du parc de machines qui nous
l'a amené on n'est pas chez va donc on
n'a pas plus de bras et de jambes
aujourd'hui que transhumanistes n'ont
pas encore gagné cette partie que de
voir les deux jambes mais donc le haut
ses adjoints de plus en plus
d'auxiliaires mécanique qui nous ont
permis de produire de plus en plus
ramené à l'individu mais ce n'est pas le
bon des dominateurs en fait et donc
d'avoir de plus en plus ramené à
l'individu de choses matérielles de
toutes sortes donc quand on a eu 40
mètres carrés habitables par personne ce
qui est la moyenne en france on ya
rajouté une voiture par ménage puis on
ya rajouté des tables des chaises etc
puis on ya rajouté une télé à écran plat
du machin des trucs et des bidules et
tout ça c'est la croissance de
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne qui nous a permis après
l'histoire dans l'autre sens va s'écrire
à peu près en mode inverse modulo quand
même un capital de connaissances et de
et d'optimisation qu'on va garder mais
ça va quand même s'écrire grosso modo
dans l'autre sens et pour finir
là-dessus quand on regarde les pays qui
ont eu la trajectoire économique la plus
chahutée en europe derrière les années
2006 c'est à dire le maintien c'est les
pays qui étaient le plus dépendant de
l'énergie qui a baissé le plus vite
ensuite c'est à dire le pétrole la grèce
60% de pétrole dans son mix énergétique
en 2006 c'est pas parce que les grecs
paient pas leurs impôts que le pays
s'est cassé la gueule c'est parce que
l'approvisionnement énergétique grec
s'est cassé la gueule alors après qu'ils
payent pas leurs impôts c'est un
déterminant du deuxième mort c'est juste
le goût à l'argent du coup ça en fait
moins pour l'état et plus pour eux mais
c'est un transfert de rente c'est juste
ça ça crée pas de la richesse de payer
ou pas payé ses impôts c'est juste un
transfert de rente c'est un arbitrage ce
qui crée la production c'est l'énergie
bon donc les provisionnements et revenir
vite y se casse la gueule le pib grec se
casse la gueule l'approvisionnement
énergétique espagnol et italien pareil
45 à 50% de pétrole dans leur mix en
2006 se casse la gueule se casse la
gueule portugal même le sol à et la
france qui n'a que 30 % ou 33 je sais
plus exactement de pétrole dans son mix
primaire se casse beaucoup moins la
gueule de même que d'autres pays qui
sont moins dépendants du pétrole que ces
pays d'europe du sud donc ce qui s'est
pas la mauvaise gestion de ces pays
encore une fois qui a fait que leur
production s'est cassé la gueule c'est
le défaut d'approvisionnement
énergétique qui a commencé soit dit en
passant deux ans avant la grande crise
financière donc ce n'est pas la grande
crise financière qui a contracté la
consommation c'est la contraction de
l'approvisionnement qui est de l'énergie
et leurs facteurs limitants de la
production qui a contracté la production
est derrière caen viendra là je pense
qu'il de l'ira a
du coup une fois toutes dettes qu'on a
besoin de rembourser avec des revenus
réels pas juste en les empruntant
puisque tout le monde ne peut pas jouer
au jeu de jarret emprunte pour
rembourser les étapes faire ça
particulier pas nécessairement et bien à
tous et en particulier la dette
immobilière des ménages américains qu'on
peut pas dans certains ont peu augmenté
dans certaines conditions et pas dans
d'autres eh bien on va commencer à être
attaqué et ce truc s'est délité et les
mêmes causes vont produire les mêmes
conséquences donc quand on parle de
contraction du pouvoir d'achat de quoi
est-ce que je parle moi en pratique je
parle du fait que c'est moins facile
d'avoir des mètres carrés d'où ce qu'on
est en train de voir se développer ou
redéveloppées la colocation etc
c'est moins facile d'accéder à une
voiture
donc autopartage transports en commun
etc c'est moins facile d'accéder à tout
un tas d'objets qui aujourd'hui coûte
pas cher et qui coûteront avec le temps
un peu plus cher n'importe quoi des
chemises des tables des chaises
les assiettes enfin voilà tous ces trucs
à le sous jacent plie aussi en fait
l'abondance énergétique a permis de
maintenir en vie des gens de 90 ans mal
portants
avec des pathologies dans tous les ans
et c'est aux frais de la collectivité
qui peut se le permettre quand le monde
était sobre en énergie au moyen-âge les
exactement il n'y avait pas deux bouches
inutiles un donc ou bien les gens
étaient galériens où on les paye quoi je
veux dire mais non mais c'était un non
mais c'est ce type sont en train dire
c'est ce qui se passe et qui gilet jaune
je suis pas en train de dire que c'est
souhaitable je suis juste en train de
dire que le monde avait sa rationalité à
l'époque s'il pouvait pas se permettre
ce luxe parce que le surplus de
production n'était pas tel qu'on pouvait
nourrir des tas de gens improductif donc
voilà aujourd'hui le surplus de
production grâce aux machines est telle
qu'on peut nourrir des tas de gens
improductifs à commencer par les
retraités les étudiants et politiciens
ça pose pas de parler pardon du
politicien et les polytechniciens ça
tout ça mais c'est ici oui j'avais
compris
toujours topinambours dans pardon donc
donc c'est c'est quelque chose qui était
la marque d'une énergie abondante le
fait que l'on puisse bien traiter des
gens qui ne sont plus capables de
produire pour la société et plus
l'abondance énergétique est marquée et
plus on peut bien traités pendant
longtemps des gens qui ne sont pas
productifs pour la société donc la
contraction du pouvoir d'achat va
attaquer tout ça et aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on se pose intelligemment la question
de savoir comment on gère ça comme on en
fait un projet positif parce que c'est
clair qu'il faut que les gens voient la
montagne sur laquelle on doit monter
comme un défi et pas comme une peine
c'est clair donc c'est voilà donc c'est
évident qu'il ya des questions de projet
collectif de solidarité d'équité de etc
c'est pas strictement monétaire l'équité
ça peut aussi être l'intensité de
l'effort le partage du stress enfin il
ya plein de manières d'être d'être
équitable entre guillemets dans dans la
façon de se partager l'effort monétaire
est essentiel parce que ça permet
d'accéder à plein de trucs qui sont
désirables donc confère ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure mais ce n'est pas la
seule manière il ya plein d'autres
l'accès aux transports en commun qui me
forme d'équité enfin voilà il ya plein
d'autres trucs qui sont pas strictement
monétaire
l'accès à la santé et donc le la
question c'est vraiment comment est-ce
qu'on transforme cette grand barrière on
voit devant nous et dont la hauteur
c'est en défi collectif qu'on attaque et
si effectivement c'est l'option dur et
qu'on retient
plus on s'y prend tôt mieux on est parce
que ce que je viens de dire longuement
sait qu'on va devoir transitionner en
décroissance on va devoir transitionner
un moyen des croissants c'est bien ça le
problème c'est bien ça le cahier des
charges alors j'avais déjà discuté qu'un
financier de ce qui se passe en
décroissance avec le système financier
compte à l'heure actuelle alors j'en ai
une fois j'ai je sais pas ce qui
m'autorise à le citer ici mais j'ai
discuté avec un journaliste économique
assez connus qui m'a dit ouf je me dirai
pas son nom parce que sinon je suis son
nom
[Rires]
bardot y en a plein mais je ne saurais
même pas au ni oui ni non apte à une
nouvelle vie et donc le il m'avait dit
de toute façon l'histoire sur la dette
actuelle c'est très simple ça ne se
terminera que de l'une des deux manière
suivante c'est par l'inflation du défaut
alors aujourd'hui c'est déjà en train de
déboucher sur de l'inflation mais les
gens le voient pas parce que c'est pas
de l'inflation sur les biens courants
c'est l'inflation sur les actifs en fait
l'inflation de la dette a créé une
inflation sur les actifs le prix du
mètre carré dans le paris où nous posons
en ce moment est en train de monter vers
des sommets le prix des actions donc
vers des sommets loup les oeuvres d'art
oeuvres d'art les matières premières la
fête c'est donc en fait c'est ça qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui le
l'endettement croissant créé par une
libéralisme enfin création monétaire
croissante libéralisme débridé oui enfin
j'avais envie dire le libéral et de la
planche à billets mais au sens de on
s'en sert de manière libérale c'est à
dire abondante c'était pas c'était je
pensais pas au système politique je
pense dit subornation de voûte
où vous dites est donc qu'ici
j'acquiesce au fait que vous dites
je vais essayer de reprendre le fil de
ma pensée donc c'est cette création
monétaire massive
a augmenté très fortement le prix des
actifs c'est comme ça que ça s'est
traduit donc ça c'est la version à la
version
à prime c'est les biens courants et la
version v6 le défaut et moi quelque
chose que je dis assez souvent dans mes
interventions c'est si vous avez de
l'assurance vie essentiellement
constitués d'obligations souveraines
ne soyez quoi si on vous dit obligations
souveraines il faut pas y voir pour des
fous c'est exactement non mais c'est ce
que je dis dit autrement si un jour on
vous explique qu'il y en a 20 % qui a
disparu
malheureusement ça sera peut-être pas
complètement
une surprise au sens de quelque chose
qu'on n'est pas capable de dire à
l'avancé
alors maintenant le jour où ça arrivera
comme ces vieux qui possède l'assurance
vie ce sera finalement une forme de
solidarité intergénérationnelle un peu
un peu expéditive
mais peut-être pas de signe un juste que
ça mais enfin voila mais ccc ça si je
mets des chiffres et si je mets des
faits la contraction dont je parlais
tout à l'heure c'est moins de biens
matériels qu'on va devoir mieux partagée
alors notre chance et pour le mans il ya
encore du gras bah oui si je prends par
exemple paris et 25% de logements vides
ou 20% j'ai pu égaler le chiffre exact
ça c'est encore du gras donc le le gras
il est facile à attaquer au sens où ils
demandent quand même un effort marginal
par rapport à un système qui se délite
totalement politiquement etc c'est
ensuite que ça va devenir vraiment
difficile mais faisons ou moins cet
effort moi c'est ça finalement mon point
de vue faisons au moins cet effort pour
le moment où il ya encore du gras ne pas
nous voiler la face et de commencer à
faire des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
faciles à accepter aujourd'hui qu'elle
ne le serons quand nos moyens se seront
contractés par la force des choses dans
un monde où par ailleurs les
perturbations externes vont continuer
d'augmenter
parce que quand le cg ou plus qui crise
en annonçant en physique parce que le
pour prendre l'exemple du changement
climatique le temps d'épuration d'un
surplus de co2 de l'atmosphère ces dix
mille ans donc le problème va continuer
d'augmenter quoi qu'on fasse si on
dépasse le seuil fatidique des 2 2 en
2005 on est parti pour dépasser
allègrement on met en route la
désintégration de la calotte antarctique
de l'ouest celle qui est face au chili
la plus une partie du groenland qui va
fondre de toute façon donc on à
l'échéance de quelques siècles on
prendra n'importe quoi entre 6 et 15 m
de l'élévation du niveau des mers bon
alors les hollandais sont peut-être très
bon en digue enfin un moment ils vont
quand même buté sur leurs limites
les français sans pardon en digue du
tout et les anciennes en plus ça va être
un défi oui les migrations climatiques
vont être local pour l'essentiel c'est
des gens ils vont aller emmerder leurs
voisins immédiats c'est comme ça que ça
va se passer donc le donc et au moment
où ces perturbations commenceront à
prendre vraiment de l'ampleur on aura
depuis longtemps passer les pics
énergétique fossile donc de l'énergie
facile par d'anciens jeux de mots qui
est celle justement qui permet de faire
face à à peu près n'importe quel
perturbations on va avoir un effet
ciseaux et plus on tarde à s'attaquer au
problème plus l'effet ciseau sera ample
et irréversible il pour vous du coup
profond
philippe si joyeux ouais non j'ai deux
remarques alors là ça va je mets un peu
de débats du coup
et on vous dit non mais en fait j'ai un
jeu que je te suis en même temps j'ai
une difficulté sur le caractère
automatique de la quantité d'énergie que
j'ai introduit versus quelque part le
niveau de vie et le développement
économique que je dois des biens
matériels je parle de la plénitude ou de
la confiance dans l'âme il y en avoir de
ski secrètement matériel mais alors pour
prendre un exemple vraiment stupide
alors c'est que ce n'est pas faisable et
ont semé ici je prône tout le parc de
voitures d'aujourd'hui de sur le
périmètre français par exemple et que je
dis toutes les voitures je transforme
les sports tu cultives véhicule c'est
les autres 4,4 et mâcha qui ont qui ont
pris un peu d'inflation en poids et en
équipements etc pour lutter contre la
déflation et la productivité quelque
part pour que parce que les entreprises
endettées avait besoin de maintenir ou
développer leur chiffre d'affaires donc
il fallait vendre des choses un peu plus
cher donc un peu plus gros seins plus
longue si je transforme d'un claquement
de doigts tout ça on des voitures à 1
litres aux cent un peu pot de yaourt
livre un poil moins vite avec même le
avec même le même nombre de personnes
non etc et donc même pour construire ces
voitures plus petites et où j'ai besoin
d'un peu moins d'acier un peu moins de
plastique à peu près tout ça quelque
part aux bornes de du pays j'aurais à
peu près le même service sauf que là est
un peu plus serré dans la voiture j'ai
un peu moins les les rétroviseurs qui
bouge et c est donc quelque part je
pourrais avoir le même niveau presque de
vie si je puis dire
mais avec une consommation de pétrole
dans ce cas précis qui seraient moindres
parce que je serais passé de chep à 4
litres aux 100 en moyenne 1,5 litre à 1
litre donc quelque part ça veut dire
qu'à un moment on pourrait imaginer
alors fait c'est pas la tendance qu'un
prix effectivement le système jusqu'à
présent mais de tailler dans le gras si
je puis dire alors c'est là qu'il faut
trouver le bon endroit et ça de manière
intelligente pour effectivement de se
dire que avant d'aller vraiment se faire
très mal dans le confort et puis
qu'est-ce que le confort alors un roman
roubles au débat tout à l'heure mais
quand on pourrait baisser cette
consommation énergétique et du coup moi
c'est ça qui me font ça c'est ce qu'on a
fait et ma deuxième remarque c'est c'est
se dire finalement j'ai trouvé une
remarque incident vazimba du couvent du
tac au tac non c'est pas du tac au tac
parce que je me suis posé la question
est en fait de deux choses l'une ou bien
cette voiture qui consomme quatre fois
moins qu'ils aient en première
approximation un peu pas quatre fois
moins lourde puisque leurs amis de m et
deux ans vraiment bref
je la vends le même prix que la voiture
d'avant et à ce moment
quelque part il ya il ya une forme
d'inflation qui moi me gêne pas du tout
mais il faut accepter l'idée que du coup
c'est pas grave ou bien on dit elle est
quatre fois moins lourde elle a demandé
quatre fois moins d'acier elle fait elle
vibre un peu plus mais moins vite et
c'est donc la vend moins cher et à ce
moment tu as moins d'ouvriers à
rémunérer et donc tu peux pas considérer
que ton système économique est restée
identique par ailleurs donc en fait ce
que tu es en train de me dire c'est que
c'est un projet de contraction de
l'économie était en train vers
compatible avec la contraction des
ressources et donc la bonne question qui
va derrière pour moi c'est si on met en
route ce genre de truc qui effectivement
résout la limite physique comment est ce
que je me dépatouiller pour que des gens
qui vont gagner moins parce que les
ouvriers automobiles vont gagner moins
puissent continuer à avoir confiance
dans l'avenir avec moins d'argent qui
rentre donc en fait il faut organiser le
système de façon plus large donc je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce que tu
viens de proposer mais moi j'ai envie de
dire en fait la difficulté c'est de
raisonner système dans ce genre
d'affaires est de dire si je contracte
les flux économiques de manière globale
comment est-ce que je réorganise le truc
pour que les gens se disent pas on s'en
fout même pas mal donc comment est ce
que je fais pour qu'ils payent moins
cher leur loyer comment est ce que je
vois c'est toute la question qui est en
fait au début je me disais la même chose
mais on va faire des mais en fait il
faut tirer le fil jusqu'au bout et se
poser la question du coût en face
je vais nécessairement avoir des gens
dont le produit de leur travail est
moins important et donc enfin voilà donc
le système doit boucler je dis pas qu'on
peut pas y arriver tu peux l'un était un
oui non mais c'est un chalet ca ca
challenge complets
découverts ils tiendront soit dit en
passant est absolument et du coup de
jute cerveau entre autres là pour le
coup des économistes finalement les
économistes hétérodoxes
pour la plupart sont plutôt des gens qui
s'intéressent à la question du
quantitative easing pour faire de la
croissance verte ou au fait qu' on
devrait un peu plus taxés en eau pour
distribuer en bas alors du coup avec
effet rebond parce que tout le monde
peut faire son week-end spa à budapest
ou je sais pas quoi ou s'acheter le
dernier smartphone et pas sur la
question de dire finalement ça serait
quoi un peu même en revenant presque à
stuart mill justin avec le ça serait
quoi une économie stationnaire ou une
économie décroissante et comment est ce
que je fais pour répartir ça parce que
finalement d'avoir moins d'argent moi je
sais pas ce que c'est l'argent parce que
l'argent sur mon compte c'est des
électrons et un moment j'ai besoin de le
convertir avec des gens qui vont vendre
des choses soient des prestations de
services de l'heure de travail soit soit
effectivement des choses qu'ils ont été
chercher dans le sous sol où une vue sur
mer éventuellement apporter leur
appartement femmes louer et est financée
qu'une manière de se répartir des biens
et services que on est tous en train de
développer donc du coup moi jouent la
question de diamants les voiliers
j'appelle ça du partage du temps de
travail
et du coup si je partage le temps de
travail je passe moins de temps au
travail je peux peut-être enfourcher un
vélo même éventuellement électrique si
j'habite à saint-etienne plutôt que
plutôt qu'avec la bordeaux etc etc donc
moi je pense qu'effectivement il ya un
travail
peut-être un travail académique énorme à
faire dans le champ de l'économie en
ayant effectivement comment est ce que
je peux faire quelque chose où il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui le taux a le le fait
qu'ils aient des taux d'intérêts oblige
à la croissance pour moin lé en fait
c'est très naïf parce que je suis que
modeste ingénieurs et pas et pas
économiste mais par pour moi du coup là
pour rembourser les soit je fait défaut
et une arme en soit il faut que le
gâteau grossistes pour que l'ensemble
des détenteurs de dettes et les
créanciers se puisse se rembourser ça
avec une gic de l'inflation
effectivement soual et oriane deviennent
négatifs qui est en train de se passer
en ce moment soit effectivement alors ça
d'ailleurs c'est un peu on peut
manipuler ça parce que les chiffres de
l'inflation va il ya plein de il ya
plein de subtilité dans les chiffres de
l'inflation est ce qu'on appelle la
fraction lundi hédonique des prix je
crois que ça s'appelle comme ça c'est à
dire c'est le fait par exemple que de
dire que l'abonnement internet et à 29
euros 99 la semaine prochaine il est à
29 ans l'année prochaine il a 29 euros
99 mais j'ai dit mais gaouaoui d'avoir 5
mégas et donc du coup il faut prendre en
compte le fait que j'aie un service plus
élevé est meilleure et donc en fait les
ombres manipulent les statistiques
d'inflation pour dire dont 29 99 c'est
comme si il était descendu à 20 parce
que ça serait ça que mes gars mais comme
j'ai dis mes gars en fait il ya eu une
déflation sur ces trucs il faut savoir
que ce requin c'est très important parce
que par exemple dans la voiture bien
effectivement lundi voitures sont plus
puissantes mais équipe et c'est donc
cette cette correction de l'inflation
elle existe elle et elle est appliquée
elle est suivie à les tracer et ça peut
expliquer en partie le le syndrome un
peu de du gars qui dit bah tiens on est
passé à l'euro la baguette de pain
exploser le café a explosé effectivement
le baguette de pain a explosé a fait
exploser on lui dit que les statistiques
d'inflation sont très faibles et
d'ailleurs on en profite pour lui dire
bon on va pas augmenter cette année
parce que tu as vu c'était 0 5% l'année
dernière c'est un grand classique est en
fait en réalité il a bien payer sa
baguette plus cher il a payé son forfait
internet au même prix que l'année
dernière mais il a plus de mégaoctets
mais du coup il ya quand même une
perception l'argent de à la fin du mois
j'ai dépensé plus d'argent parce que
j'ai acheté des baguettes et a forcé au
même prix certes pour un service
meilleur presque dire c'est un peu comme
si la ratp disait mon prix du mais le
prix du ticket de métro a pas baissé en
fait il a baissé parce que maintenant je
fais des annonces en anglais dans le
métro donc voyager c'est qu'un un
service qui est plus sympathique donc on
vous fait l'inflation le calcul
inflation je pense est un petit peu
frelaté et devrait être un piège les
données conventionnelles en fait
exactement donc pas ce que j'allais dire
c'est comment est-ce qu'ils posent après
aujourd'hui c'est que nous on est là
c'est un peu entre nous on se dit un
monde comptera en ressources tout ça
mais il ya plein de gens qui se pose pas
cette question là et aujourd'hui on est
quand même à se dire dans l'immense
majorité des cas le débat c'est est ce
qu'on va assez vite ou pas assez vite
sur le déploiement des renouvelables
quoi et puis sur la rénovation thermique
du béton et la garantie
attendant l'énergie voilà et est
aujourd'hui quand on regarde et je il ya
des cocoricos fatale croyons plutôt des
les articles s'enchaînent alors c'est en
2018 la mi 2010 8 on a passé le mil giga
watt installé au mondial en néo lien et
en solaire formidable et depuis 3 4 ans
déjà le nombre de gigawatts qu'on
installe en éolien et en solaire est
plus important que jimmy waite au
charbon super sauf qu'évidemment dès
qu'on soulève le capot on m'a d'abord un
gigawatt en solaire et en éolien ça fait
pas un gigawatt forcément charbon parce
que il ya ce facteur de capacité ça
tourne pas toute l'année dans un cas et
dans l'autre oui et quand on regarde ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui au niveau
mondial l'électricité entre les derniers
statistiques que j'ai vu c'est celle de
bp là qui sont disponibles sur internet
assez facilement entre dont 2016 et 2017
2018 est pas encore sorti on a augmenté
la consommation électrique mondiale de 6
100 térawattheures 600 milliards de
kilowattheures du mois en 2000 en un an
donc à peu près la production électrique
française pour faire à peu près simple
en ordre de grandeur sur ses six ans
térawatts heures supplémentaires une à
300 qui sont venus de l'éolien et du
solaire super 300 sont venues des
fossiles essentiellement du charbon
aujourd'hui on n'arrive même pas à
accompagner la croissance c'est pour ça
que les émissions de co2 continuent à
augmenter donc de là à se dire qu'on va
remplacer qu on a substitué par l'effort
industriel est monstrueux toutes les on
se retrouve avec une société à regret
sobriété
charland qui ralentit la chine prévient
que la croissance sera plus faible la
chine continue d'installer des chantres
à charbon en veux tu en voilà on a une
question d'internet qui vient de tomber
à quoi ressemble une société avec mon
énergie
alors avec beaucoup moins d'énergie à
une société médiévale
de la corruption que vous y avait pas de
corruption il y avait surtout pas de
démocratie parce qu'en fait la société
stable dont parlait philippe tout à
l'heure est une société dans laquelle je
ne peux pas promettre plus de tous de
tout à tout le monde ça tient pas donc
c'est une société dans laquelle il faut
que les gens soient fataliste acceptent
leur destin ce qui par don expliqué il y
avait les deux en même temps
tocqueville explique très bien quand
aristocratie des gens sont fatalistes
voilà donc on n'a même pas besoin de
l'expliquer parce que et on voit là
c'est le monde est immuable il est comme
ça est bon
et aux guildes dit aussi que la
démocratie rend les gens jouisseur dans
imerys on se pète heures à l'heure ça
est très bien expliqué 1840 et donc est
donc là
c'est facile de le dire physiquement
c'est beaucoup plus facile de beaucoup
plus difficile de lire sociologiquement
le les gros angle mort alors si je
prends l'exemple de dégâts watts par
exemple qui font un très bon boulot
d'ingénieurs les deux gros angle mort de
leur scénario c'est l'angle économique
et l'angle sociologique en fait leur
scénario est un scénario de contraction
ils n'osent pas le dire donc ils ont
pris un économiste du cired en disant
que le pib allait augmenter quand même
avec ça allait créer des emplois mais
c'est d'une hypocrisie sans nom est par
ailleurs le deuxième gros angle mort
c'est comment est ce qu'on fait pour que
les gens acceptent en démocratie par
exemple que l'espace habitable par
personne n'augmente plus qui revient par
exemple à interdire les divorces et le
bdk août pardon et le but des 40 bd 40
c'est à dire 40 lits béton balles de
caoutchouc non je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit suffisant pour régler pour les
divorces dans vienne parler donc le donc
la question c'est aujourd'hui une
dépression à la hausse de l'espace
habitable par personne et de la crise du
logement c'est les divorces corps un
certain nombre d'élus locaux m'ont dit
les gens que je vois arriver moi dans
mes services et qui veulent des
logements sociaux c'est les familles
monoparentales dans typiquement des
mères ou qu'on jamais été en couple ou
qui viennent de quitter leur conjoint et
qui ont besoin c'est donc le
question si on dit qu'on va limiter la
quantité de mètres carrés disponibles
pour l'ensemble de la population en
pratique je fais comment jeudi ou
polyandrie ça dépend de comment il en
reste chaque ouais moi j'ai mes
préférences personnelles mais on va pas
s'engager dans ce débat donc là là le
sujet il est après très sociologique
c'est à dire que techniquement ce qu'ils
disent et physiquement possible ça pose
pas de problème il ya aucun problème
ce qui le sujet c'est la contrepartie
économique et social dit autrement est
ce que cette contrepartie économique et
social elle est
vraisemblable dans son chemin même pas
dense on danse on danse dans la photo
d'arrivée est ce que je sais vendre par
exemple aujourd'hui le fait que le
divorce va devenir considérablement plus
difficile parce que j'ai pas envie de
construire des appartements à tire
larigot est ce que je t'ai vendre ça bon
je ne sais pas à mon avis pas facilement
un deuxième un deuxième exemple sur
entressen data mère quoi oui bah c'est
l'ancien on est d'accord ou duo d'ex
union soviétique on est d'accord
deuxième c'est très compliqué de marier
un univers de contraintes avec un
univers de liberté or la démocratie est
quand même un univers de liberté et
aujourd'hui on essaye quand même de
résoudre quelque chose qui est il
expliqué c'est fondamentalement deux
directions qu'ils sont
qui sont orthogonale ou en face et c'est
pas du tout les dimensions autant le
vrai un peu là on sache un peu basses
classes et c'est très masculin c'est un
peu léger non c'est une interrogation
profonde
l'avenir si sociétal l'inertie sociétal
qu'on a pris avec plus de liberté à la
télé réalité tout facile on a fait
miroiter à l'afrique on a fait miroiter
en afrique grâce à internet nos besoins
de consommation il donc louis do de nos
envies nos désirs ainsi de suite est-ce
que l'inertie sociétal c'est à dire que
ses 30 ans un peu plus car autant
oursins plutôt de siècle web et les
trente glorieuses océan s'est gavé là ça
va tout va bien on a conditionné tout le
monde est ce que vous pensez pas que le
déconditionnement va se faire dans le
son qui partiellement j'ai déjà souvent
dit on est déjà dur est en train de
prendre le début des claques j'avais
écrit en 2000 chez puis ces onze ou
treize un article qui s'appelait marine
le pen enfants du carbone et je
j'expliquais angres ou alors je vais pas
dire j'avais prévu les gilet jaune mais
j'expliquais que si on devait commencer
à avoir des problèmes ça serait dans ce
genre de couches sociales et dans ce
genre d'endroit et précisément à cause
de la décrue pétrolière pour moi c'est
même un chapitre de mon dernier bouquin
donc à dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100
évidemment c'est une petite blague sous
aux éditions odile jacob
19,90 e aux appareils non essais c'était
en 2004 était coup c'était un
quinqua que nos cycles un but leur dire
je sais plus s'il est recyclable ou
pages vous avouerez clé ça serait mieux
reçu le farsi classe et plus je sais
plus
par contre ce que je sais c'est que pour
moi ça c'est un c'est quelque chose qui
est très cohérent avec un pays qui est
déjà en contraction énergétique relative
pour le moment elle n'est pas violente
elle est allée elle est relative ce sera
plus violente dans les égouts de la
faune des choses comme ça alors ce qu'on
avait vu en egypte alors si l'egypte où
c'est lui alors l'egypte pour moi est
aussi corrélée c'est un autre chapitre
du même bouquin est en fait il ya eu
deux déterminants dans ce qui s'est
passé en egypte est soit dit en passant
en tunisie est soit dit en passant le
déclenchement de la guerre civile en
syrie c'est la même année donc il ya 3 3
événements concomitants au proche orient
et qui ont été la conjonction de trois
facteurs
deux qui sont climatique inquiète
énergétique le facteur énergétique dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est le pic
énergétique de la zone ocde en 2006
derrière problèmes économiques crise
financière en 2009 et à ce moment les
touristes restent chez eux
s'ils se convertissent ip ils sont à
saint barth oui mais le gros des
touristes restent chez eux donc recettes
à l'exportation de pays à forte
dépendance au tourisme que sont la
tunisie l'egypte
le maroc aussi maintenant que tu as cas
plus particulier par la syrie évidemment
baisse
et dans le même temps on a un stress
croissant sur le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen un stress hydrique
croissant dans le cadre du changement
climatique endémique et en 2010 on a un
double processus qui s'applique on a une
remontée des cours du pétrole
qui entraîne dans son sillage une
remontée du cours de toutes les matières
premières parce que toutes les matières
premières sont asservis au pétrole pour
des tas de raisons auxquelles jamais
rien compris enfin c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
et par ailleurs grosse canicule en 2010
en russie et il se trouve que cette
canicule a quasiment divisé par deux la
production de céréales russes et la
russie est un gros fournisseur à
l'exportation sur le marché mondial
le marché mondial des céréales en gros
c'est 10% des céréales qu'on consomme
dans le monde donc c'est un marché
étroit et là dedans la russie en fournit
entre 15 et 20% donc c'est un gros
fournisseur du marché mondial
en juillet je me rappelle très bien la
russie 10 cette année nous exporterons
pas overnight le cours du blé à la
bourse de chicago prend 30%
donc l'augmentation les importations
alimentaires dont l'egypte qui est le
plus gros importateur de blé au monde et
qui rapporte tout un tas d'autres trucs
parce qu'il ya longtemps que le nil de
n'aurait pu ses habitants et la tunisie
qui bon an mal an apporte la moitié de
ce qu'elle mange les importations
alimentaires de ces pays-là explosent
alors que leurs recettes à l'exportation
se sont cassé la figure dans le sillage
de la crise énergétique donc financière
de 2006 et donc on a une cisaille
énergie climat qui s'appliquent à ces à
ces pays là et on a eu des émeutes de la
faim alors une bonne partie des
journalistes français ont dit ils
veulent la démocratie je t'en fous ils
voulaient d'abord manger oui donc on a
eu on a eu à 1788 1789 c'est exactement
ça qui s'est passé alors le maroc est un
peu plus particulier parce que ils sont
plus ils ont une agriculture de
subsistance plus développé que les
autres pays sont moins importateurs de
denrées alimentaires donc ils s'en sont
mieux sorties clan voisin et l'algérie à
bach et ses importations par le pétrole
et le gaz dont le cours remontait mais
l'algérie c'est la prochaine egypte
c'est à dire vers julie qui les
subventionner ces produits
d'alimentation parce qu'ils avaient les
moyens parce qu'ils exportent du pétrole
et gaz et au lieu des camps et quand
leur le pic de production du pétrole est
passé en algérie le pic de production du
gaz est passé en algérie donc quand les
exportations de pétrole et de gaz de
l'algérie commenceront à devenir
suffisamment basses avec une population
suffisamment élevé sur un sol pas
capables de nous et c c'est écrit alors
je sais pas quand mais c'est écrit je
vous la parenthèse henry critère
spéculatif oui oui oui ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est des tendances
lourdes qui sont à l'oeuvre la
spéculation ajoute de la volatilité par
dessus ces tendances lourdes donc ça
rajoute des oscillations est en fait
celle oscillations qui à un moment de
façon conjoncturelle va déclencher la
crise mais mais mais ces oscillations
elles sont autour de tendance lourde
philippe
je pense que dès qu'on commence à parler
d'eux deux conséquences ou d'émeutes de
maisons de l'évolution sociale un petit
peu dur il faut très vite distingué un
peu les régions effectivement parce que
moi je pense qu'effectivement des
émeutes de la faim ou une vraie ou en
tout cas des déclenchements de migration
complémentaires par rapport à toutes les
velléités qu'on a déjà aujourd'hui dans
des pays comme comme effectivement
l'afrique lors sa non au sud du sahara
çà çà çà çà va effectivement revenir
c'est un exemple mais il peut y en avoir
d'autres sites venezuela et dans une
tenaille qui est pas très loin d'être la
même actuellement parce que leur
production agricole mais alors là je
sais pas si c'est dû au climat il faut
que je regarde a fortement diminué sur
les dernières années dans le même temps
que le cours du pétrole s'est cassé la
gueule et c'est l'essentiel de leurs
recettes à l'exportation donc je je
pense que c'est les raisons sont
peut-être pas climatique sur la
production agricole je regarde mais par
contre ils sont dans une tenaille qui
est la même c'est à dire baisse des
recettes à l'exportation donc il ya il
n'y a pas que le moi il n'ya pas que le
proche orient non mais je ne sais
d'ailleurs il yad'autres vainement mais
où on fait un exemple effectivement sans
doute s'est enfermé matic parce que les
fictions il ya quand même des bombes à
retardement démographique dans ces pays
là qui restent encore même s'il ya un
peu transition et que les rassurant
populatio nist de l'ined et d'autre et
de quelques autres
d'organismes nous explique que tout va
bien il ya quand même aussi cette
tendance lourde la qui existent et qui
va parce qu'il n'est pas l'unique
facteur bien sûr du problème qu'on a
mais qui va qui est un paramètre parmi
d'autres et qui forcément plus on sera
nombreux plus ça va quand même être
compliqué d'une manière ou d'une autre
mais
une fois qu'on a dit ça ça change rien
on a une tendance qui est ce qu'elle est
après si on vient un peu dans nos dans
nos pays à nous si je puis dire moi j'ai
peut-être pour me rassurer mais j'ai
beaucoup de mal à avoir les émeutes de
la faim quand même de tout de suite en
tout cas parce que on a tellement
d'abord de alors oui on est dépendant
bien sûr du gaz pour la partie et
nitrates des phosphates marocains et de
la potasse canadienne ou le contraire
mais non je crois pas que ça soit le
contraire pour une agriculture du
pétrole etc il y avait cette fameuse
histoire de dire je belle 10 calories de
pétrole pour produire une calorie
alimentaire mais c'est aussi en comptant
effectivement tous les emballages toutes
les usines et tous les camions qui
tourne et les supermarchés et les
voitures qui vont faire leurs courses au
supermarché qui se gavent dessus voilà
mais globalement quand on regarde quand
même les grands paramètres alors un ange
est 35 3 % de la nourriture à la
poubelle en europe
qu'en plus con ça commençait par finir
nos assiettes collectivement alors il ya
plein de raisons pour ça c'est pas
facile il ya des dates de péremption il
ya le collectif il ya de la taille des
menus dans les restaurants il faut
revenir à des meubles des plats du jour
et puis c'est tout parce que ça fait
moins de gâchis il ya plein de choses
comme ça
2 la quantité de viande qui
effectivement tu penses au leader déchu
et ses premiers déterminant arrive
en mangeant un peu du un peu moins de
viande ou beaucoup moins de viande en
libère des tombereaux de céréales et on
peut même se permettre d baisse du coût
de rendement baisse de rendement qui
seraient impliqués par le fait d'avoir
deux d'être un petit peu moins peut-être
violent sur les intrants dont on peut
utiliser
et donc voilà ça fait quand même déjà
deux paramètres très très fort et puis
ici c'est vraiment on avait des sujets
de dison de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
pétrole de gaz ou aux bas on peut aussi
un moment flécher les choses plus
intelligemment alors faut avoir
effectivement en ce moment là des des
pouvoirs relativement fort pouvoir
étatique ou pouvoirs régionaux en sérère
bons qu'ils puissent dire pas en gros
c'est de dire une croyance grève dans
une raffinerie dans les raffineries 1
c'est arrivé pour des raisons non c'est
le contraste énergétique la sortie des
raffineries bayala que la station
service et les premiers qui passe c'est
les voitures de pompiers des ambulances
et des voitures de flics quoi donc on
peut aussi dire qu'à un moment il faut
du pétrole pour mettre dans les
tracteurs et les moissonneuses batteuses
avant de le mettre dans les week-ends
chez les beaux parents donc ça c'est des
choses qui surtout chez les beaux
parents surtout chez vos parents se
rassurent énergétique un l'instauration
d'un cottage éthiques oui tout certaine
manière c'est le fait de pouvoir en tout
cas assuré des
dix approvisionnements aux secteurs qui
sont vraiment stratégiques et la
nourriture l'est pour dire outremont des
bons alimentaires
ça passera je sais pas leur avenir oui
cette question de la du rationnement
alors il ya des il ya des conserveurs
des études qui sortent sur ces questions
du rationnement de commencer a été vécue
pendant pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale le fait que c'est relativement
bien vécu en général à condition que ce
soit
équitablement réparti justement donc
déjà est ce qu'on parle de bons qui sont
échangeables ou pas échangeables parce
que on peut les il y avait cette
question d comme pour les permis
d'émission de co2 est ce qu'ils sont et
ce qu'ils vont sur un marché en fait ce
qu'on veut ou est ce que c'est vraiment
chaque personne et puis on va nager mais
bon mais je peux pas dépasser à un autre
que c'est bon moi je suis je pense que
ça a introduit une pour l'instant une
complexité supplémentaire
et qu'on est vraiment très très loin à
nouveau de ce sujet la phase 1 pour
l'instant
quand bien même j'irai on aurait une
contraintes d'approvisionnement
en pétrole où on ferait je sais pas -30%
-40% alors ça serait ça créerait des
vraies difficultés mais on se remettra à
parler à nos voisins
on serait obligés de s'organiser avec
trois co voiturage un peu pénible sans
un nouveau jeu taper dessus c'est bien
oui c'est peut-être envisager s'il faut
avoir faim pour se taper dessus je crois
enfin c'est bon pour se mettre devant un
char ou devant des policiers armés ça
dépend quel excellent parle comme zizou
tenons c'est ça ça dépend à quelle
échelle on parle en fait alors je vais
pas dire une connerie parce que je suis
pas historien mais j'ai l'impression que
la réaction face à la contrainte elle
est plutôt solidaires à une micro
échelle et elle est plutôt hostile à une
macro échelle c'est à dire que c'est les
peuples qui se tapent dessus mais
l'école et les communautés locales ont
plutôt tendance à se serrer les coudes
j'ai l'impression donc ça va dépendre de
l'échelle à laquelle on parle il
exacerbe une facture guerre économique
ça exacerbera les tensions de toute
nature
guerre économique ou autre après ça va
aussi beaucoup dépendre de la culture
des peuples les etats unis c'est quand
même un pays qui s'est forgée par les
arbres en zigouillant les indiens dont
que la violence physique c'est un truc
qui leur est familier les chinois c'est
un peuple assez peu belliqueux il
conquiert le monde de façon économique
en discutant en négociant et c'est donc
ça va quand même prévu apparemment en
2049 d'avoir la plus grande armée du
monde si j'ai bien compris donc oui j'ai
extrait du oui mais c'est quand même
historiquement un peuple qui a été moins
en moins oui et intrusif et
et enfin voilà c'est pas leurs réflexes
habituels koala états unis c'est
vraiment volé trop pourquoi
mais c'est très difficile on a envie
revenir à la vieille blague
faire des prévisions c'est difficile
surtout quand ça concerne l'avenir c'est
ce qu'on le sujet dont on est en train
de parler en fait il faut le comparer à
la tectonique des plaques c'est à dire
que ce qui est facile c'est de
caractériser les grandes tendances qui
sont en mouvement là où ça complique
donc là où on a pour reprendre le
langage de la tectonique des zones de
subduction des rifts et des machins de
savoir très exactement où quand et de
quelle magnitude sera tremblement de
terre est ce que ça va tuer pierre plus
tôt paul où ça c'est que là on rentre
vraiment dans la spéculation pure ce
qu'on fait c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile soit dit en passant parce que
les gens qui doivent prendre des
décisions mais il aime bien décidé face
à un truc est à peu près précis dans sa
description et qui arrive telle année
plutôt que tel autre ou le lundi plutôt
qu'un mercredi donc c'est clair que ça
nous facilite pas la vie ne pas être
capable de dire ça de façon précise pas
ce que tu peux faire mais c'est que tu
peux et cette notion de résilience qui
est très à la mode oui dans les
territoires etc et qui est de se dire
finalement à chaque fois que je prends
une décision est ce que je me par
rapport à ce monde mouvant complexe
internationalisé et c est ce que je suis
en train la décision je prends va me va
me m'exposer encore plus à des risques
arrivant de l'extérieur et des
difficultés des pilotes et spéculatifs
et autres ou est-ce qu'au contraire
c'est plus et non pas je fais pas un
repli mais je vais avoir une tendance va
en laisser plumer les gens les gens s'en
rendent pas compte alors je donne un
exemple aujourd'hui on continue à mettre
des grandes surfaces en périphérie dans
ce pays avec du reste le plus
emblématique et projets délirants qu'au
niveau du triangle de gonesse au nord
donc les élus commence par dire je vais
coller des grandes surfaces ce qui est
un truc qui les rend moins résilient
parce que du coup tu rend les gens plus
tributaire de la voiture pour aller
faire leurs courses et puis ce furent
tués à proville seul tu as prouvé que tu
allonge les chaînes logistiques de la
fabrication de ce que tu vas trouver
dans ton magasin tu supprimes un lien de
proximité avec les commerçants de
centre-ville parce que même si c'est des
affreux jojo c'est quand même plus
facile d'être proche avec eux qu'avec la
caissière qu'on voit une fois tous les
quinze jours dans un hypermarché et donc
on va commencer par faire ça qui est pas
du tout un gain en résine on
est pas parce que je reviens à ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure parce qu'aujourd'hui
les gens n'acceptent pas de traiter le
problème dont on est en train de parler
qui est on va devoir faire avec moins
dans la région les politiques oui enfin
les gens qu'ils décident d'une manière
générale
quand on a une décision à prendre c'est
très très rare qu'on s'organise cette
manière
oui alors c'est dans une autre rubrique
on pourrait dire le
fantasme de la smart city
en imaginant que ça va être
des capteurs un peu partout fabriqués en
asie du sud est avec des matières
premières de 50 pays différents
avec des données qui seront stockées sur
des datacenters islandais ou n'empêchera
pas les nationales étasunienne est ce
que c'est vraiment la meilleure manière
d'aborder lors du 21e c'est pour moi le
smart machin c'est la seule définition
que je connaisse c'est le truc magique
qui va régler tous nos problèmes
faites moi confiance fait rien confiance
pour que je vous dise ensuite ce que ça
sera effectivement comme ça que j'ouvre
une parenthèse imaginer je vous mets
luron élections d'autres vous deux mais
il résiste combien de temps ça dépend à
quoi
on essaye de l'embrasser de le
convaincre qu'ils nous paient restaurant
soit le défi son argumentaire est ce qui
résiste aux choses pure bonté rateur de
stabilité énergétique
non mais si vous essayez de convaincre
un curé que dieu n'existe pas c'est
compliqué donc notre homme il est dans
le postulat il n'est pas dans la
démonstration
d'un postulat de la loi de moore on
pourrait dire celle amenée dans le
postulat progresse comme ça en maille et
le vertical lit dans le postulat donc à
postulat ça ne se combat pas puisque ce
n'est pas une démonstration une
démonstration ça se combat postulat
basse et si je postule que les gens qui
meurt d'une crise cardiaque sur terre
c'est parce que les martiens leur ont
envoyé des ondes si des martiens non pas
les marxistes les martiens
ou les jupitérien c'est enfin
je postule voilà donc s'il n'y a pas de
débat vraiment c'est je postule donc
laurent alexandre il postule qu'il ya
des tas de trucs qui vont se passer mais
c'est pas une démonstration si l'abonné
je sais pas il sera sur lui-même
probablement peut-être qu'il essaye de
rassurer d'autres personnes les
transhumances fonds de commerce plutôt à
l'étranger les transhumanistes vous
savez c'est des gens au fond ce qui
n'ont pas de problème et qui sent la
vente
donc c'est né aux états unis de gens qui
ont déjà à plein à manger plein d'argent
plein de machin ils ont le seul truc qui
le reste c'est d'avoir peur de mourir
donc il s'occupe de ça voilà parce que
tout le reste il ya plus de problème et
pour partie ce sont d'ailleurs des gens
qui ont fait fortune dans le numérique
dont les milliardaires de google
conquérante et quelques ballets et donc
ils ont 20 30 ans pour trouver le truc
quoi voilà pas se faire écraser en
traversant la rue et puis s'ils se font
écraser en traversant la rue ils peuvent
toujours se faire par le génie zay et se
font essayé attendre de faire réveiller
dans des siens sous des cieux plus bas
ils seront ils font reconstruire mais
c'est en fait c'est l'incarnation d'une
peur cette histoire là
au fond peur de la mort l'ornement une
coupure du pauvre on regarde ça c'est le
concept plutôt néo zélandais lassé de
côté puis un trial là qui sait il
suffira de regarder alors on le le
meilleur métriques c'est le nombre
d'habitants au kilomètre carré quoi donc
alors la france on est à 120 je crois
dans ça c'est en version canton moyenne
is parce que si on retire les vosges les
cv mais tout ça aura été si je prends
les ce si je prends les 30 départements
les plus peuplés je crois qu'on est à
trois cents habitants par kilomètre
carré ce qui est déjà un petit peu plus
donc là on est à peu près du niveau de
la hollande à ce moment là le bangladesh
est à 1000 donc c'est fait qu'on
pourrait faire face mais une une france
à 500 millions avec le même donc voilà
n'ayant pas peur et montant jusqu'au
ciel puis la nouvelle zélande froide et
a fait plus et 15 ou 25 est quelqu'un
qui veut faire du fac tchéquie en
comptant les hobbits ou pas alors en
cours tant seigneur des anneaux dans une
maison de hobbits je crois bien non une
question jean-marc tué au couteau ou
conseils pour le climat le gouvernement
va dans le mur ou écoutent ou alors pour
le moment ni l'un ni l'autre
n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre tout simplement
parce que le haut conseil existe depuis
novembre dernier fait il a toujours pas
été formellement créées puisqu'il sera
créée par une loi qui sera votée je peux
encore cette année
on a eu trois réunions c'est un mandat
essentiellement bénévoles ou qui sera
payé de manière symbolique mais enfin
bon essentiellement bénévoles
c
et on a signé pour deux jours par mois
parce qu'on a tous des activités à côté
voilà donc la réponse est dans ce que je
viens de dire c'est évident que pour le
moment on est déjà simplement en train
de discuter entre nous pour savoir ce
qu'on va considérer être notre mandat
est ce qu'on va avoir envie
de formuler des recommandations d'action
est ce qu'on va avoir envie de formuler
simplement des constats ce moment
comment est ce qu'on les structures est
ce qu'on a envie de faire un rapport
parent qui portera sur un sujet
différent histoire de pas se répéter à
chaque fois que la trajectoire est pas
respectée enfin voilà donc on est en
train de discuter entre nous en ce
moment
le la seule chose qui est sûre c'est que
dans la alors là je vais donner une
conviction personnelle je vais pas du
tout donner ce que je crois être le rôle
du haut conseil ma conviction
personnelle c'est que l'intérêt de cet
organisme sera celui qui nous sera fera
le crédit qu'on va pouvoir gagner non
pas auprès des politiques parce qu'on
sort à une injection comptant une
injonction contradictoire parmi 50 mais
auprès de tous les gens dans la société
civile qui auront un peu le temps de
lire ce qu'on va raconter enfin bon ce
qu'on va écrire quand qui auront un peu
envie de discuter du sujet et qu'ils
pourront faire quelque chose du travail
d'analyste qu'on aura fait c'est ces
gens là qui nous intéresse parce qu'en
fait c'est ces gens là qui ensuite
peuvent faire pression sur le monde
politique en disant ce qu'on a lu nous
aident à préciser nos envies nos
arbitrages et donc on a envie d'un peu
plus de ceux ci est d'un peu moins de
cela c'est ces gens là à mon avis pour
moi un qui sont intéressants a visé dans
le cadre du haut conseil on dépend
formellement du premier ministre il n'y
a pas un premier ministre qui dira notre
apport in extenso parce que toute façon
pour reprendre aux quarts un premier
ministre c'est quelqu'un qui décide
toutes les deux minutes sur un truc
qu'il a pris le temps de regarder donc
voilà donc c'est passé c'est lui notre
client formelle mais en fait c'est pas
lui notre client notre client et après
il ya un deuxième client qui est ce
qu'en dira la presse et la presse comme
chacun sait elle sélectionnera dans un
truc qui va faire 100 à 200 pages trois
phrases qu'elle trouvera sympathique et
qui résume ont correctement ou pas ce
qu'on aura fait
résumé pour décideurs donc oui mais même
là dedans aux pages qui vont bien même
là dedans si on parlait du nucléaire
philippe qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur le nucléaire
alors ce que je peux dire d'abord je
suis pas un spécialiste je suis pas un
ingénieur nucléaire donc
moi ce que je dis c'est que
toujours sur une question de laquelle
terme on parle mais si on veut tenir
comme pour reprendre les mots de jean
marc il me semble que à moyen terme le
nucléaire n'est pas une solution du tout
parce que j'ai des objets qui sont par
définition pas trop recyclables un
circuit primaire de centrales nucléaires
je peux pas je peux pas faire des boîtes
de conserve avec et donc
si je veux tenir milan avec avec des
centrales nucléaires et bien faut que je
refasse 20 fois de suite une génération
de centrales les unes derrière les
autres ça me paraît un peu compliquée à
la fois en termes d'aménagement du
territoire est à la fois en termes de
consommation de ressources parce que là
pour le coup est ce que dans 500 ans on
aura du nickel du cobalt et truquant
disponibles donc j'ai un problème sur le
fait que deux pour brest c'est pas une
solution durable du point de vue dans la
cause de la consommation de ressources
non renouvelables dans tous les métaux
qu'il faut bon pour les méthodes pour
mettre là-dedans a causé un nombre
cyclabilité ensuite j'ai un problème à
plus court terme ce qui est un problème
de résilience c'est à dire effectivement
j'avais été un peu choqué par le parrain
très beau reportage sur le site donc à
l'eau en finlande donc de de stockage
souterrain des déchets il y avait des
des officiels de de
7,7 du nucléaire en finlande et les gens
disent ah oui pourquoi est ce que vous
voulez les enterrer finalement et après
parce que le monde est en train de
devenir instable donc on va pas les
laisser traîner n'importe où pour
n'importe qui du coup j'ai envie d'y
revenir si vous êtes sûr que le monde va
devenir instable est ce que vous êtes
vraiment sûr qu'il faut laisser des
centrales nucléaires donc moi j'ai cette
question là de dire je sais que jean
marc secondi c'est du caire où la guerre
civile en tout cas en france moi j'ai
envie d'en france à dire tiens si jamais
il ya une guerre civile je veux pas
qu'ils aient du nucléaire avec et puis
après j'ai enfin un peu technique sur la
question de la du bouton marche/arrêt
ont il me semble que quand on voit là
c'est le truc où on dit j'appuie sur un
arrêt en fait ça s'arrête pas vraiment
complètement faut que je continue à
avoir des ponts pour refroidir faire
tourner l'eau en être sûr que ça se vide
pas dans les piscines etc terrain je me
dis mon dieu mais en 2002 sens si on n'a
pas enterré tout ça et que on a encore
des piscines avec plein de trucs qui
continuent à chauffer je crois que j'ai
un espèce de service civique obligatoire
avec des gens qui tourneront sur des
pédaler sur des vélos pour refroidir les
piscines le central face à un peu comme
dans soleil vert où il ya des gars qui
casse le le bitume
à la main parce que je sais pas quoi
retrouver les champs dessous bon là ça
me donne pas très envie voilà donc c'est
à cette question de la résilience et la
question de la durabilité sur le moyen
terme et que du coup quitte à faire un
effort de transition ans contraignant et
bien autant le faire en mettant le
paquet en terme de deux moyens et
d'énergie si je puis dire eve moyens
humains sur cette transition est pas se
mentir en disant finalement je peux
encore tenir 40 50 ans il suffit de vous
remettre quelques quelques centrales je
marque alors je vais résumer ma pensée
en une phrase pour moi le nucléaire est
un amortisseur de la décroissance
c'est à dire que je ne reviens pas sur
ce que j'ai dit jusqu'à maintenant je
pense que le monde va se contracter je
pense que un monde dans lequel on dit
je ne je n'utilise pas le nucléaire dans
mon chemin dans ma transition parce que
c'est bien la question du chemin alors
d'abord je vais rassurer tout de suite
philippe je pense que dans 1000 ou 2000
ans il ya longtemps qu'on sera fait
péter la gueule ou plus exactement il ya
longtemps qu'on n'aura plus une humanité
à 6 milliards d'individus donc savoir si
on doit avoir des centrales nucléaires
pour l'humanité qui à cette époque là
sera au descendu à n'importe quoi entre
50 et jeux pour combien 500 millions
d'individus c'est pas la question de
savoir si je dois en avoir aujourd'hui
pour sept milliards d'individus c'est
déjà pas cette question là donc je pense
que la question du nucléaire à très long
terme entre guillemets est une question
qu'aujourd'hui on peut laisser ouverte
parce qu'il ya des paramètres
dimensionnant
considérablement plus importants qui
font que enfin voila on peut en discuter
toute la nuit ailleurs très sympathique
je pense qu'on n'arrivera pas à se
mettre d'accord sur des chiffres pour
deux raisons évidentes enfin en tout cas
moi j'arriverais même pas mettre
d'accord avec moi même sur les chiffres
donc là donc la question du nucléaire
pour moi elle ne s'inscrit pas dans
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans 2000 ans
j'y reviendrai après parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de sujets et qui pour moi
ne m'empêche pas de dormir elle se passe
dans dans l'est dans le siècle qui vient
et le chemin
c'était la question de tout à l'heure
l'atterrissage ou là où je pars koala
dans le chemin et siège amène justement
vers un soft landing je pense que de ne
pas faire de nucléaire augmente les
risques augmentent augmente le coup de
poing ou les coups de poing qu'on se
prend par rapport au fait d'en faire la
sacema conclusions globales hors après
j'ai un tout petit peu détaillé quelques
faits premier truc à une anecdote que je
trouve assez marrante qui est aussi dans
mon dernier bouquin c'est que le plus
vieux stockage de déchets nucléaires il
a 2 milliards d'années
pardon au gabon au gabon et au clos est
alors en fait il ya un réacteur qui
s'est mis naturellement en
fonctionnement dans une mine d'uranium
et les descendants des déchets sont très
exactement là où on les a là où les
déchets sont apparus donc en fait le
déchet nucléaire c'est un caillou 1
c'est un truc qui est solide noyau non
non le corium c'est autre chose c'est un
recteur qui a fondu les déchets
nucléaires c'est des produits de fission
alors tout à l'heure la question était
qu'est-ce que le nucléaire va nucléaire
s'est cassé en deux au noyau d'accord
donc c'est pas iqualuit c'est ça
l'énergie nucléaire s'est cassé des
noyaux poser cette question d espagne 6
et s'il y avait
il ya eu un moment le bon braquet porte
qu'est-ce que donc l'énergie nucléaire
s'est cassé des noyaux en deux donc
c'est pas brûler des atomes à c'est
autre chose c'est pas oxydée des atomes
et une fois qu'on a cassé noyau en deux
on a deux plus petits noyaux qui sont
radioactifs c'est ça qu'on appelle les
produits de fission les déchets
nucléaires et ça c'est des cochonneries
effectivement il faut s'en tenir
éloignés alors pour le moment ces trucs
là en france sont dans une piscine en
surface à la hague
moi comme père de famille je me dis
qu'ils sont 400 mètres sous terre à bure
je me porte plutôt mieux parce que la
probabilité qu'ils nous rejoignent c'est
la figure comme début on l'a me paraît
pas très élevé il faut savoir que le
confinement géologique ça tient des
centaines de millions d'années les
réservoirs de pétrole y en a qui sont
confinés géologiquement depuis des
dizaines de millions d'années ces
liquides ses souffre et c'est chose et
en plus ça bouge pas quoi donc non
géologique vous entendez que
l'enfouissement oui le fait de médecins
dans une bille d'argile et d'oublier un
peu un peu comme en allemagne en
allemagne non je sais pas ce qu'ils font
exactement en allemagne
je connais pas je connais pas la
tradition ultime en allemagne mais enfin
ce qu'on veut faire en france est un
truc qui m'empêchera pas de dormir le
deuxième sujet en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire sur le côté high-tech en fait
le nucléaire est beaucoup plus low-tech
les éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
c'est quand même un c'est quand même des
machines qui sont apparus avec des
contrôles commande analogique est du
reste le contrôle commande chez nous est
toujours analogique dans les centrales
c'est la première pile c'était 42 être
pas le p r quand non alors justement on
a sophistiqué à l'excès il faut faire du
low tech dans le nucléaire aussi c'est à
dire que le truc qu'on a fait le prc
beaucoup trop compliqué on a fait
ceinture et bretelles pour ceux sur
protéger contre des risques qui ont des
probabilités d'occurrence qui sont
faibles - est-ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est un peu provoc mais c'est
encombrant des cigarettes et qu'on vend
des bagnoles je suis pas complètement
persuadé
j'ai beaucoup plus peur pour mes gosses
quand ils traversent la rue quand ils
vont en soirée où il ya des clubs du
temps et tant qu'on fait dans l'aigu
retour c'est qu'après des ressources et
qui crée du terrorisme alors je continue
parce qu'il ya des vrais sujets encore
une fois il est vrai les faux sujet donc
la sécurité des installations nucléaires
d'avoir encore une fois c'est des trucs
qui sont plus low-tech et c'est des
trucs qu'on peut très bien dimensionné
pour que s'il ya un pépin saffon ça
reste dans la centrale on a perdu la
centrale point l'art et puis voilà je
quand on regarde les chiffres on se rend
compte que comparé aux alternatives et
notamment aux centrales à charbon le
nucléaire est un plaisantin le charbon
tue chaque année 500 mille personnes
dans le monde si je bois et boutabout
les accidents dans les mines rien que çà
rhin et les maladies professionnelles
des mineurs je parle même pas de la
pollution urbaine il ya 10 millions de
charbon aux deux mineurs de charbon dans
le monde
regardez les études de cohorte qui ont
été faites sur les mines de charbon
français en france la quantité qui sont
morts de suites de maladies
professionnelles dans les 5 10 20 ans
qui ont suivi en retraite c'est
hallucinant donc si on regarde les morts
il ya pas photo dès que je remplace du
charbon part du nucléaire j'ai fait une
bonne affaire même si je coure un risque
d'accident une fois sur deux sens
pourquoi si on regarde l'environnement
j'ai fait une encore meilleure affaire
parce que quand une centrale pète tous
les hommes foutent le camp donc ça crée
une nature il ya des très beau reportage
de la bbc sur ce qui se passe autour de
tchernobyl où la nature a repris ses
droits alors qu'elle avait été évacué
par l'agriculture intensive soviétique
donc il est plus de castor il y avait
plus de l'unc ce qui l'est plus c'est
pourquoi tout ça est revenu
l'étude sur le trailer du kurde alors
les travailleurs nucléaire ils sont pas
beaucoup plus irradiés que les hôtesses
d'easyjet
des études sur les cd sous traitants ou
c ou et parce qu'ils sont suivis tous
ces gens là sont monstrueusement suivi
alors le grand paradoxe c'est que ces
gens-là sont globalement en meilleure
santé que la population française parce
que comme ils sont terriblement suivi à
cause de leur profession on détecte
beaucoup plus tôt chez eux toutes les
cochonneries ordinaire que la population
française attrape donc c'est un truc
c'est un phénomène étonnant
donc je suis ce que je suis en train de
dire c'est que alors la bonne question
pour moi ans qui dansent en fait en ce
qui concerne le nucléaire c'est pourquoi
on en a si peur
alors que quand on regarde les chiffres
et les faits il ya des tas de trucs qui
devrait nous faire beaucoup plus peur
deepstack à commencer par le fait qu on
bazarde des phytosanitaires partout dans
la nature ça me fait beaucoup plus peur
que les déchets nucléaires fabien ont
fait vingt tonnes de déchets nucléaires
en mer dans par an dans ce pays on
bazarde 50 mille tonnes de
phytosanitaires dans la nature bon les
déchets nucléaires sont pas en train de
tuer les insectes le s'acidifient pas
l'océan ça crée pas de stress
alimentaire donc on a dans la gestion
des priorités parce que moi c'est ça mon
sujet c'est la gestion des priorités je
mets vraiment le fait de se débarrasser
du nucléaire voit devoir de ne pas en
faire plus j'insiste tout en bas dans
l'échelle des risques et donc j'ai envie
de dire pour le moment on est dans la
station spatiale internationale qui est
parti pour s'écraser à la surface de la
planète le le fait qu' il ya des trucs
qui présente transitoirement de petits
inconvénients je pense qu à actionner
les rétrofusées ça fait du bruit non
mais on est on ne sait de fukushima non
mais faut kojima n'a pas fait un mort il
ya à cause des rayonnements ionisants il
ya il ya une commission onusienne qui
s'appelle une star qui a le même statut
que le giec qui a fait un rapport sur
fukushima il n'y a pas un journaliste
français quant à parler et ce rapport
dit très exactement ceci c'est une noir
sur blanc dans le rapport que n'y aura
pas de conséquences sanitaires à cause
du surplus de radiation c'est écrit noir
sur blanc donc cesser le tsunami a fait
28 morts
l'accident de fukushima en tant que tel
maintenant on n'en a pas fait voilà où
est donc bientôt et ce qu'ils auront
contrôle de thyroïde commis en france où
des choses dans les cancers à la
thyroïde en france ont commencé à
augmenter dans les années 70 c'est à
dire quinze ans avant-hier 2000 et il
n'y a pas de rupture de pente sur
l'augmentation de l'incidence
au moment de l'accident il soit dit en
passant les études épidémiologiques
montrent que ceux qui ont eu des
problèmes à tchernobyl c'est les enfants
au moment de l'accident parce que les
adultes ont arrêté d'accumuler liaudat
vitesse à grande vitesse une fois qu'ils
sont adultes et donc euh y'a pas de
surplus de cancer qui a été détecté chez
eux je vais finir en donnant une
indication quantitative quand on relit à
une base de données qui s'appelle pubmed
qui recense tous les papiers qui ont été
publiés dans des revues médicales à
comité de lecture nature de leur ancêtre
la new england journal of medecine etc
et quand on fait une recherche dans
cette base de données avec le mot clé
qui a radio nucléides donc
radionucléides en anglais je crois de
mémoire qu'on trouve deux cents ou sept
cent mille références donc en fait les
questions de l'impact des rayonnements
ionisants sur la santé c'est quelque
chose qui est étudiée depuis très très
très longtemps la commission de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants en date de 1928 on a étudié ce
truc là depuis très très longtemps il ya
une énorme matière et je le redis la
bonne question c'est pourquoi est ce que
dans notre pays il ya un tel schisme
entre la connaissance accumulée dans les
milieux qui s'en occupe et ce camp
comprend le grand public parce qu'il ya
un certain nombre de sujets pas beaucoup
mais celui là on est vraiment
emblématique il n'y a pas beaucoup de
sujets environnementaux qui sont comme
ça mais celui là est vraiment un sujet
dans lequel il ya un énorme écart entre
dans d'autres ya de la confusion etc
mais ya pas de cet énorme écart et ça
c'est un sujet intéressant à mon avis
reconnaît philippe est ce qu'on vous dit
là dessus oui peut-être juste un point
c'est que en mettant tout ça à part
après il ya la question un peu de la
capacité de déploiement industriel alors
chargé la limite voilà quand on voit
alors et c'est pas une raison pour se
passer de ce qu'on a déjà alors c'est ça
que et c'est pas une raison pour moi au
carénage plutôt que du neuf parce que
oui et même et moins et même du neuf
pour remplacer les centrales à charbon
chinoises ça me va très bien je veux
dire je suis pour figer votre toit oui
mais finalement enfin je m'interroge sur
comment finalement la france fait quand
même un peu effectivement une exception
c'est aussi une exception sur sa
quantité de deux centrales qu'on a qu'on
on a pu installer et je m'interroge sur
finalement ce grand programme des années
70 80 est-ce qu'on serait capable
aujourd'hui de le renouveler dans un
monde un peu dans le monde le livre un
marché non voilà et puis peut-être avec
effectivement moins je sais pas de
capacité de penser rien de bétonnage ou
autre ah oui c'est très clair et en fait
c'est là qu'on voit que l'économie de la
connaissance ses biens avaient connu des
connaissances mais finalement on la
confond très vite avec il ya plein de
tuto sur youtube et puis c'est super on
est tous assez de la connaissance
finalement académique on pourrait dire
si je tape sur wikipédia et donc
l'économie de la connaissance est en
fait dont il ya plein d'autres il ya
plein de sortes de connaissances et à
des connaissances qui se transmettent
pas bien par youtube alors tu es sétif
deschamps blanc les champignons de
reconnaître des champignons dans la
forêt c'est il faut qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui montre à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est transmis mais
la formation pendant très longtemps
jusqu'à l'invention de l'écrit au moins
et puis il ya un autre type de
connaissances et des connaissances
organisationnel débute par des
entreprises migration sert la capacité à
avoir des gens qui ensemble à peu avec
la complicité d'antan paraît tout à
l'heure qui sont des milliers des
dizaines de milliers peut-être ensemble
vont réussir de manière coordonnée à
faire quelque chose et celle là elle se
délite assez vite et espère ça s'appelle
les départs à la retraite rappelle ça
s'appelle éventuellement une
libéralisation et puis d éventuellement
des priorités qui sont données qui sont
pas forcément les peut-être qu'ils
privilégient du court terme par rapport
à du long terme et c est en fait voilà
je moi j'ai l'impression que c'est qu'on
a un peu perdu le fil alors je sais que
là on être le pm chinois par exemple est
en train d'être mis en service ou une
ethnie les îles et enfermement ils vont
en tout cas côté show il aurait eu
l'avenir de la moitié de flamanville
voilà et quand je vois flamanville et
puis
le père finlandais non non c'est parce
qu'ils en ont 20 en construction donc
ils ont ils ont cette organisation ayant
une filière organisée et donc ils ont
dit plutôt me dit voilà et du coup voilà
moi la question c'est finalement
justement parce que le nucléaire il est
pas très appétissant au plein de gens
parce que c'est pour des bonnes et
mauvaises raisons voilà pas la peine de
compass trop de temps dessus mais du
coup est ce que tout ce qu'on peut
recréer une filière a tiré les bonnes
personnes et jeunes ingénieurs des trucs
moi je vois là encore je reçois des
messages c'est plutôt bonjour tiens moi
j'ai pas du tout il bossait dans la
vraie vie qu'est-ce que je peux faire au
secours bon et j'ai pas grand chose à
répondre souvent d'ailleurs mais et donc
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas certain
qu'on soit capable de relancer de
ramener quelque chose comme ça un effort
industriel dans un secteur qui n'ont
plus à pas bonne réputation pour des
bonnes ou des mauvaises alors ce qui
aujourd'hui est un vrai sujet c'est
l'économie ouverte parce que le
nucléaire c'est comme les
infrastructures de transport etc comme
beaucoup d'autres sujets très
capitalistique c'est quelque chose qui
ne naît pas spontanément dans le libre
marché parce que ça c'est un truc que tu
connais bien entre domaine aussi quant à
une infrastructure très capitalistique à
très longue durée de vie dans une
économie ouverte où tu mets tout et
capitaux en compétition avec du
rendement à 10% tu ne fais rien voilà
donc en fait tu ne fais pas plus un
réseau de chemins de fer que tu fais des
centrales nucléaires dans une économie
ouverte où les conflits ou les capitaux
sont en compétition entre les licornes
de la silicon valley et le fait de faire
des trains ou des centrales chez nous
donc d'une manière générale tout
programme industriel à large échelle
pour faire des infrastructures de grande
dimension ça ne peut pas faire
l'économie d'un état fort hood une
puissance publique forte qui sait où
elle va et qui dans ce domaine la saps
abstrait du libre marché il lui reste
c'est coché ces coquins d'anglais il
sait très exactement ce qu'ils ont fait
avec les 'points ils ont inventé un
mécanisme anti marché
et leur prix garantis exactement et en
france comme en europe les nerfs quand
on a voulu les déployer parce que c'est
aussi très très payer on a inventé un
truc anti marché qui est le tarif de
rachat donc en fait d'une manière
générale gérer un monde en contraction
dans un marché ouvert ça ne marchera pas
ça ne marche déjà plus aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'il ya c'est ça qui a amené le
break site pour moi et la montée du
populisme en europe c'est aussi un truc
que j'explique dans mon américains et
c'est évident que le monde en
contraction avec
le libre marché partout et tout le temps
et les capitaux qui vont saluer là où
sont les meilleurs rendements marginaux
résiduelles ça ne peut pas construire
spontanément un monde bien organisés et
résilient ça ne sert ne marchera jamais
donc si on le veut on le décide et comme
dit notre jeune suédoise là on le fait
on fait pas mais si on décide de le
faire à ce moment on le fait de manière
dirigiste parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
méthode qui peuvent fonctionner alors
appel à nos amis économistes qui nous
regardent donc dans ce travail académie
qui à là question de de remise en cause
du dogme la croissance c'est quoi une
solution économique post croissance et
puis ya aussi la remise en cause de deux
effectivement delà de la concurrence et
de la compétition à tout prix où là
aussi c'est une question d'échelle
c'est-à-dire tout on a la chair on prend
tout le monde arrive à comprendre que le
boulanger du coin on a envie de pouvoir
changer le boulanger si on n'est pas
content parce que je sais pas quoi on
sait pas bien fait traiter on est
d'accord et puis à côté de ça il ya des
trucs peut-être des grands réseaux alors
télécoms énergie en france figurent
total transport ou autres firmes ont du
mal à quelqu'un on le voit la logique de
la dg compte de la commission européenne
est peut-être légèrement revoir parce
que ça marche pas tout le temps ou quoi
c'qui des choses à rajouter j'avais
envie d'aborder un sujet
vous avez deux dernières volontés
[Rires]
non les gens là on n'est pas tombé comme
ans et auteur de
je vais je vais peut-être revenir sur le
fait que dans nos sociétés complexes en
fait il ya il faut plus que raisonner
par cible je suis raisonner par priorité
alors maintenant si on a des priorités a
exprimé dans le contexte qu'on a évoqué
il y en a une première qui est de faire
l'effort accru de comprendre où on en
est et de comprendre que les indicateurs
économiques ne suffisent pas nous
expliquer où on en est il ya un deuxième
effort important qui est sur la manière
de s'organiser dans un monde sous
contrainte donc on parlait tout à
l'heure d'une économie qui doit se
réinventer l'économie était
historiquement la gestion de la
ressource rare alors il ya deux siècles
ce qui était rare c'était bon homme
aujourd'hui ce qui est rare c'est lent
heureusement séparent les deux hommes on
a trop de bons jeunes mais du chômage
partout et du reste rentrer au capital
et des bulles spéculatives partout donc
on a besoin d'avoir des outils de
pilotage l'économie c'est un outil de
pilotage qui soit adaptée à la situation
qui est aujourd'hui et quelque part ça
c'est la mer c'est la mère de tous les
combats c'est à dire que je dis qu'ils
en août
ils étaient quinze jours est bon alors
il est peut-être qu'on doit obliger les
gens à se former quid base ball mais
vas te former ou je te tire de suivre sa
marche pas bien donc le temps qu'on n'a
pas fait l'effort de comprendre à quoi
ressemble tant qu'on n'est pas arrivé à
comprendre le problème à traiter et à se
doter d'une manière de l'attaqué on est
quand même un peu à poil et donc entier
ont jugé donc on s'est dit tiens on va
[__] cinq milliards là dedans
peut-être que ça marchera peut-être que
ça marchera pas et puis je tripote les
potards ici et je tripote les potards là
et je te des taxes le travail je te re
taxe machin puis ça marche toujours pas
parce que en fait l'auteur peut-on sur
mes photos sur la tv
ça marche ça marche toujours pas parce
que quand on tire on juger la
probabilité même d'élever 40 la
probabilité qu'on tape juste là où on
veut et quand même assez faible donc le
le premier truc qu'il faut vraiment
essayer de me dit comme combat c'est le
combat pour le coup de la connaissance
c'est à dire de la compréhension de là
où on est je vais tous les politiques
c'est plus
compliqué que ça parce que nous ou
contre nous parce que si on les sent
glace se barre des gens qui savent pas
mieux que les précédents où est le
problème à traiter s'est pas
complètement sûr que la situation va
s'améliorer
donc non non c'est vraiment un effort de
chacun
voilà je pense qu'il ya un vrai un
énorme ce sujet là dessus
et après on peut discuter entre nous
mêmes faire cinq cent mille bus etc ça
changera pas la face du monde
si on donne rendez vous chez menu le
maquereau mais même emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron est quelqu'un qui répond
aux injonctions de la population c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne un président
il n'est pas du tout ce président
symptomatique oui alors il est
symptomatique d'une époque parce que
quand on regarde moi qui suis
suffisamment vieux pour les avoir connu
le je suis frappé par le fait que depuis
que nous n'avons plus de présidents
issus de la guerre
c'est à dire le dernier en date était
mitterrand on a des présidents qui sont
taillés pour arriver au pouvoir et qui
sait pas quoi en faire donc plus un
gamin qui déjoue et d'adultes salon
c'est un gamin qui veulent jouer mais il
sait pas pourquoi donc chirac chirac
chirac n'a pas su quoi faire du pouvoir
sarkozy n'a pas su quoi faire du pouvoir
s'il a fait la libye
où ils conversent un campagne il avait
pas de il avait de temps en temps des
impulsions mais ça participait pas d'un
projet construit si il avait un projet
un peu construit qui a une qui n'a pas
dit son nom je pense qu'il était fasciné
par les etats-unis
non mais c'est mon avis personnel vous
voyez son fils parce que quand on voit
l'augmentation du pouvoir du parlement
la réforme de la justice et cetera son
discours anti haute administration c'est
un ajout étranger au fait vous fait vous
vous faites vous même et c'est je pense
qu'il avait une petite fascination pour
les états unis mais il n'a jamais dit et
exprimer comme ça c'est young leaders
vous nous oui je peux en parler après
s'amuse ensuite jeu
on a eu hollande qui est arrivé un peu
par hasard et puis on a macron qui est
arrivé après les dix petits [__] et
qui ne sait pas quoi non plus faire du
pouvoir donc on a on a eu
essentiellement des présidents qui ne
savent pas quoi faire du pouvoir et ça
c'est symptomatique d'une époque
parce que je pense qu'on a globalement
une classe politique qui a totalement
perdu ses repères c'est ce que je disais
en entrée donc je pense vraiment que
tant qu'on ne sait pas tant qu'on n'a
pas une boussole et une carte on peut
discuter de ce qu'on veut
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a enfin voilà le on va
continuer à bouchonner a tiré à droite à
gauche et c'est là gentiment se déliter
et a gentiment s'effondrer parce qu'on
comprend pas l'origine du problème c'est
absolument évident pour moi voilà donc
ça je pense que c'est un truc qui est
vraiment important à mes yeux
parce que c'est le seul étage 1 de tout
le reste si on fait passer philippe moi
je prendrais parle aux deux bouts
il est nécessaire elle suffisante on
sait ce qu'elle est nécessaire en plus
de mal sur ce que peut être le
suffisante tout ça est malheureusement
non plus étant là aussi sur des
questions d'échelle c'est qu'on peut
réfléchir un franco français mais quand
bien même on rentrerait dans une super
dans un super monde enfin dans un super
france contraignante un peu l'eau
technician etc qui réduirait ses petits
pots de ses voitures à des petits pots
de yaourt et puis tout à coup se faire
envahir par ce qu aurait pas fait la
même chose je n'en sais rien en 2060
donc il sait tout ça est un peu
compliqué moi j'aurai je dirais comme
moi j'ai envie de revenir dans passion
peut-être le mot était pas le bon sur
les hommes politiques web ou femme
politique visionnaire mais on a un poème
de rêve quoi quelque part on est en l
homme et les câbles et joue une
parenthèse qui sur internet c'est pas la
destination ce chemin vous avez un
exemple de chemin ou d'un début de
chemin qui vous semblent intéressants
voire enthousiasmant bah oui c'est
d'ailleurs justement je voulais
je finis et jeu et je complète
exactement en répondant serre que je
pense qu'il faut qu'on change de rêve
aujourd'hui on a un peu les mêmes rêves
que historiquement c'est à dire on veut
on veut gagner plus on veut dépenser
plus on veut se montre de la corne
d'abondance on veut vivre plus vieux ont
même être immortel on peut revenir sur
les mythes grecs et autres on veut
d'avoir avoir des esclaves alors c'est
de techno esclaves c'est une
intelligence artificielle demain des
voitures autonomes et autres donc c'est
le en gros de dire je veux je veux je
veux jouir dans l'abondance et sans
travailler en étant immortel quoi donc
c'est pas trés trés nouveau tout ça ça
fait 3000 souhait ça fait 4000 5000 ans
peut-être qu'on doit à peu près
raisonner comme ça un minima depuis
qu'on est rentré dans le néolithique à
peu de choses près et donc aujourd'hui
au regard des bonimenteurs s'est inscrit
sur toutes deux annoncées parce qu'ils
surent thunder non
on a aujourd'hui des bonimenteurs un peu
technologique c'est à dire ça va de
l'aude musk qui m'a avec voilà c'est
qu'en plus on prend pour on fait
semblant de prendre pour les sauveurs de
la planète mais qu'on va aller sur on va
aller sur mars et s'était alors en
attendant on habite falcon roquettes on
va lui faire faire new york
tokyo un peu plus rapidement parce qu'il
faut trouver aussi il faut que les
marchés le quantitative easing et les
capitaux les attire donc du courant
national espèce de truc qu'on continue à
être un peu fasciné comme des lapins
pris dans la lumière des phares à chaque
fois qu'il ya une espèce de nouveautés
technologiques et une fioriture et qui
sont vraiment des tartes à la crème
enfin en tout cas le le meilleur côtoie
le pire et c'est plus du pire que d'une
manière souvent faut qu'on change ce
rêve là et donc qu'est ce que ça peut
être le rêve effectivement c'est on a
tous un job on mange mieux
on a peut-être pour nos enfants un peu
plus accès à une nature qui est pas
juste complètement contrôlé et qui sont
juste des parcs d'attractions et des
pistes de ski intérieur ou pas
maintenant je crois que finalement un
bonnet sinon conçoit pas la piste de ski
mais il fait voilà et moi je pense que
j'ai qui montrent un logique de postes
croissance alors post croissance
décroissance on l'appelle comme on veut
pour pas se faire peur de pleine
activité de plein emploi ou ont fait
plus ses confitures soi même on est plus
à vélo on a plus partagé le travail
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui c'est
la ressource abondante ces puits la
ressource rare comme au 19e siècle donc
on voit un exemple concret je serai là
là encore je sais pas puisque les
économistes en direct ce que les housses
que les
hauts fonctionnaires de bercy en frais
mais aujourd'hui on a soit l'ensemble de
des cotisations
1 l'assurance maladie chômage retraite
sur le travail humain 450 milliards et
la taxe carbone se doit être quatre ou
cinq quelque chose comme ça avant ou
après gilet jaune voilà mon coeur donc
du coup 450 milliards 4 milliards voilà
la manière d'aujourd'hui en arbitre le
truc si je m'étais l'ensemble de ses
cotisations sociales du travail chez les
essayer sur une fiscalité tout le monde
vous remonterez son aide pas mal ça
commence plutôt pas mal puis après bah
du coup ceux qui auraient un
comportement écologique vers ce qu'on
pourrait se permettre ou qui voudraient
un peu changé des modes de vie
finalement ils pourraient ils pourraient
dépenser leur argent avec des choses qui
seraient plus cher la matérialité ferait
plus cher parce qu'il y aurait cette
taxe carbone ne dansait pas être sourd
voilà c'est un exemple parmi d'autres et
c'est parce que ça peut donner ça peut
marcher si ça peut être si c'est peanuts
ou si ces facteurs de transformation
mais on pourrait faire plein de choses
et en fait ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que dans cette société
qui porte l'innovation au pinacle c'est
un fait refait alors qu'en fait on est
dans une société de la peur tous on
innove parce que ça nous emmerdent
d'innover mais on innove le couteau dans
le dos parce que le chef a dit créé d
innover ou parce que le concurrent a dit
qu'il fallait innover ou parce que le le
pays d'à côté en train d'innover donc on
est là talent il faut y aller faut y
aller encore à courir bien en réalité on
fait de l'innovation technologique mais
par contre qu'est ce qu'on est prudent
sur les innovations économique sur les
innovations politiques parce qu'il y en
a un paquet de trucs ambitieux tester et
sociales y en a un paquet de trucs ans
pourrait tester sur la politique sur la
manière de celui ci en présentant la
manière dont que semble penser d'une
heure ici
pas mal mais je comprends que c'est je
comprends que ça soit considérée comme
un outil dangereux parce que la liste
des questions qui pourraient sortir pour
être des questions qu'on n'a pas envie
de se poser on appelle demeurant les
migrations lives et j'ai un mariage pour
tous et donc
c'était trop chaud qu'il faut axer rosso
qui disait démocratie est un système
trop parfait pour les hommes
oui ça marche mais le diable est dans
les détails il peut en sortir le pire
comme le meilleur ça dépend beaucoup de
la maturité de la population vis-à-vis
de ce genre de mode de fonctionnement
par exemple les votations ça marche bien
en suisse parce que c'est un pays très
consensuel très habituée aux débats
travail etc en france on a quand même
pris l'habitude de répondre non pas la
question mais à celui qui la posent
donc c'est donc c'est un peu et du reste
ce que les anglais ont voté sur le break
site
c'était pas un vote sur le break site
c'était un vote sur leur état de deux de
confort
psychologique à ce moment là donc
beaucoup de gens qui étaient pas
conformes ou non mais aussi va avec seul
à dire autrement je l'inconfort
psychologique
et s'incarne toujours dans quelque chose
dans mon test d'internet la suisse est
habituée aux débats grâce ou votation
pas nourrir ce bas c'est la question de
la poule et l'oeuf
moi je pense pas ça je pense qu'en fait
il ya un déterminisme géographique aux
cultures est qu'une fois que le
déterminisme géographique a fait la
culture à ce moment les institutions
s'adapte à la culture c'est ma vie c'est
ma vision climat rue de personnes rue de
personnes collaborative et je vais
préciser un peu quand on regarde les
pays en europe aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
habitués à la décision par consensus on
voit les pays scandinaves
la suisse est d'une certaine manière un
peu la grande bretagne qui est quand
même un pays plus
plus un peu plus que nous et c'est que
des penan et
d'une certaine manière aussi un peu la
corse c'est à dire des zones qui étaient
rudes ou isolés parce que l'hiver
scandinavia trois siècles il fallait s'
leplée l'hiver dans la montagne au
suisse il ya un siècle il fallait s' le
peler les suisses étaient les plus
pauvres des européens avant que tu seras
content genre d'horreur sur la suisse au
début du 19ème c'est sûr c'est pas vrai
qu'ils avaient des gares de suisse enfin
il envoyer leurs mercenaires en tout cas
mais ils ont fait des grèves la séance
est en fait là le fait de fournir des
exactement malthus explique que les
armes et à la fois les appeler nous les
invasions barbares et limite c'était de
l'export de population surnuméraire que
la production locale n'arrivait pas à
nourrir donc le donc le donc ces pays là
se sont forgé une obligation de
collaborer parce que sinon personne ne
survit qui c'est qui s'est incarné dans
leur culture et du coup comme ils sont
obligés de collaborer ils peuvent avoir
des débats adultes y compris sur des
sujets qui ailleurs diviserait quand la
vie est trop facile les gens sont moins
obligés de collaborer et en fait si on a
une lecture alors il est un peu
grossière mais je pense qu'elle marche
assez bien si on va des pôles vers les
tropiques en fête au nord on ad on a on
est limite de la population humaine
suffisamment nombreuses pour faire des
états mais on a des états qui sont très
collaboratif si on va un peu plus vers
le sud où la vie a été un peu plus
facile vous avez des arts d état un peu
plus braillard un peu plus désorganisé
donc la france un peu plus que la suède
et l'italie un peu plus que la france et
si vous aller encore plus au sud on a
historiquement eu des cellules fin des
sociétés qui n'avait même pas besoin de
s'organiser à la maille d'un état pour
assurer la solidarité donc en afrique
l'état est une création colonialiste
avant ça n'existait pas parce que ce
n'était pas utile pour organiser un
partage dans une société où ils
poussaient des trucs toute l'année et
c'est donc alors c'est un peu grossier
ce que je suis en train de dire mais je
pense que c'est assez représentatif de
ce qui a forgé la culture et du coup
derrière les institutions reflète la
culture donc donc ça marche bien en
suisse je le répète je suis pas du tout
convaincu que ça marcherait aussi
facilement que ça je dis pas qu'il faut
pas faire l'expérience mais faut bien le
faire comme une expérience pas comme un
truc définitif en disant on va faire ça
c'est sûr que ça marche est-ce que vous
avez un philippe est ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les gili joudes
moi c'est dangereux ça
j'ai tout plaisir le faire sous forme de
plaisanterie
enfin parce que bon on sait jamais ça
devient de plus en plus liberticides
tout ça je sais pas c'est moi ce qui m'a
ce qui m'a interpellé
donc j'ai je ne sais pas forcément le
l'ensemble des revendications qui
peuvent être un peu bigarrée et sur
lesquels on peut effectivement piocher
des choses très intéressantes et puis
des choses qui font qu'ils sont moins
intéressantes au moins moi sympathique
au moins pertinente ce qui m'a
impressionné c'est la panique la panique
du pouvoir quelques parts d'audience
mais bon dieu même dans un pays aussi
installer que la france on pourrait dire
finalement une révolution c'est ça tient
juste sur les salaires de ceux qui
tiennent la matraque et et si ça peut se
retourner finalement peut-être très très
vite et cette espèce de logique de
panique sur le mode à l'ifo s'exfiltrer
parce que en bas il ya un chariot
élévateur car enfoncé la porte du
ministère je trouve ça assez incroyable
donc
enfin en tout cas ça m'a interpellé
voilà donc je vais pas dire que c'est
bien que c'est pas bien mais conseille
pas le conseil ccc si jamais il y avait
encore des portes de ministères enfoncé
qu'elle le soit pour des bonnes raisons
jean marc
bourgineau liting oui oui voilà non mais
je n'ai pas conseillé un
d'enfoncer les portes de ministères je
le précise bien pour jean qui pour
répondre aux énigmes maintenant mais pas
tellement un conseil pour les gilets
jaunes gepetto un conseil pour ceux d'en
face
il me conseille pour le gie joffrin le
conseil pour le fossat j'ai fait un
conseil pour ceux d'en face alors le
conseil pour ceux d'en face c'est de
comprendre que c'est ce que je déplore
c'est pas tout est tellement une
surprise que la détresse s'exprime
chez ces gens là avec ce déclencheur là
est la question de la mobilité à ce
moment là voilà donc en fait le monde
mon conseil il est surtout pour les gens
d'en face c'est prenez le temps de
correctement analysé
le les tendances de fond qui ont créé ce
truc là et comprenez bien que si ça
n'est que le début quelque part dans
l'effondrement temps on parlait tout à
l'heure en fait je vais revenir sur ce
que disait philippe parce que c'est
connectés est-ce qu'on va mourir de faim
dans 20 ans je ne crois pas comme il l'a
dit il suffit qu'on divise la quantité
de viande qu'on consomme par deux ou par
trois et on a encore largement de quoi
manger et on a encore largement de quoi
manger pendant encore quelques décennies
ou pas par contre ce que je crois c'est
que la contraction va d'élite et les
structures qui sont pas prévues pour ça
et donc ça va se traduire avant tout par
des troubles économiques sociaux
politiques etc et géopolitiques et et de
l'instabilité qui va secouer le système
de manière croissante et donc pour moi
les gilet jaune c'en est un marqueur je
vais pas dire attendu mais logique
cohérent avec l'évolution d'ensemble
c'est la tecktonik dont je parlais tout
à l'heure
donc je sais pas dire quand aura lieu le
tremblement de terre mais quand il y en
a un je sais dire c'est logique qu'ils
en aient un parce que c'est la tecktonik
voilà c'est exactement pareil les gilet
jaune je sais dire c'est pas étonnant
qu'on ait un truc comme ça
et je le redis dans une perspective à
quelques décennies c'est que le début
donc dernière question qui n'est pas une
question s'est laissé un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
philippe à moi j'en avais déjà né sait
rien il ya un an alors je sais plus trop
ce que j'ai ce que je vais dire ça peut
être le même ouais non je l'avais dit ne
pas céder aux sirènes technologie
dernière fois mais au delà chose j'irai
de 2,2
de garder espoir et optimisme néanmoins
parce que parce que voilà il faut
quelles que soient les circonstances et
quel que soit
l'avenir qui est pas écrit d'abord enfin
j'espère
et
il y aura des chemins de vie il y aura
des trajets il ya des possibilités de
s'épanouir des procès d'avancé et il
faut taper dans la but même si même si
le chemin paraît compliqué trois livres
a conseillé
le mien le prochain parce que je
remarque qu'à citer que ce cas tout cinq
fois plus les deux passés du tiens voilà
c'est bon non non non
lewis mumford
soit le mythe de la machine soit soit
technique et civilisation dite très très
très sympa
et puis bah john kenneth galbraith la
nouvelle était industriel je trouve que
ça décrit bien de toute la problématique
un peu technologique dans laquelle on
est en fait jean marc mais punition le
conseil aux jeunes on les livre livres
et le conseil aux jeunes
comme on a beaucoup parlé politique ce
soir moi j'ai un intemporel a proposé
que j'adore qui est la démocratie en
amérique kabyle parce qu'il n'ya pas
dire que la changer aujourd'hui
je vais faire comme philippe je vais
proposer aussi bien
pierre bellemare sur 12 secours le
dernier c'est pas sympa parce que je
suis vieux et quand même pas à ce point
là encore mais en plus est
le
le troisième
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de proposer sur
le troisième ce que j'ai envie de
proposer un livre additionnel de
compréhension ou est ce que j'ai envie
de proposer
à l'époque je vais rester dans la
compréhension là aussi un intemporel
c'est le l'édition 2009 172 des limites
à la croissance voilà parce que ça
permet de bien comprendre ce que c'est
qu'une dynamique des systèmes est ce que
c'est de encore une fois comment comment
est-ce que le monde s'organise et
comment est ce que les choses sont liées
après les conseils aux jeunes
générations je vais en donner un premier
s'est passé du temps à comprendre ce qui
se passe et tant que vous n'avez pas un
paysage cohérent sous le nez continue à
creuser dit autrement au début quand on
commence à chercher on recueille les tas
d'informations dont on arrive qu'on
n'arrive pas à mettre en cohérence
d'accord ben moi ce que je dis c'est
tant qu'on n'a pas sa cohérence interne
il faut continuer à creuser et à
chercher jusqu'au bout alors c'est long
c'est ensuite un truc que j'ai bien aimé
que m'a dit le cocher un jour on avait
une interview ensemble il a dit ne
restez pas seul j'ai bien aimé parce que
effectivement on prend quand même une
sacrée baffe dans la figure quand on
comprend et donc c'est essentiel
psychologiquement 2
de ne pas être seul youtube pardon j'ai
touché du tout ouais enfin fo à quelque
part il faut avoir c'est l'équivalent
des alcooliques anonymes faut avoir des
gens qui parlaient lecture ne dit plus
tôt ouais ou les houles et où les
stresser anonymes ou les réalistes
donner des carbonisant anonymes ou les
romans faut les appeler mais est du
reste pas anonymes faut mieux se
connaître mais donc ses cd parce que
c'est important de créer quelque part
une communauté d'intérêts autour de ce
genre autour d'un sujet quel qu'il soit
pour parce qu'on se décale par rapport
au reste du monde quand on comprend ce
qui se passe toujours donc on sort un
tricks quoi quand on sort des
communautés existantes serre si je suis
pour prendre une population je connais
un peu sympa pour être élitiste je suis
jeune ingénieur dans une boîte et puis
je me prends la double sur d'eau froide
sur la tête tout d'un coup je me
désolidarise de fait don d'une partie
des gens avec qui je bosse parce que
c'est la course à l'échalote dont on
parlait tout à l'heure que je commence à
me dire à quoi bon j'ai impérativement
besoin de recréer une autre communauté à
côté où je me sens bien donc voilà donc
ça ça c'est un truc qu'il faut pas
négliger
il faut avoir des projets collectifs
c'est en fait l'action créé l'espoir
c'est sûr du rêve oui mais l'action créé
l'espoir et ceux qui tuent l'espoir en
fait c'est de démarrer une action dont
on pouvait dire à l'avancé qu'elle
pourrait pas marcher justement parce
qu'on n'a pas pris le temps de
comprendre dans quel univers on évolue
mais à partir du moment où on démarre
quelque chose qui peut marcher
à ce moment l'action créé l'espoir c'est
voilà donc c'est important aussi de
faire des choses pas nécessairement très
ample pas nécessairement etc et de faire
des choses de manière collective et nous
vous conseiller un poème à
renoncement de saint pierre
messieurs merci c'était trop court
on voudrait invitera pour aborder
d'autres sujets ensemble merci encore la
soirée at war
[Musique]